hello YouTube Mike two on
YouTube live on YouTube now say Mike one
Live on
YouTube how your
mic
live Mike three online do I have mic
three
don't
worry
camera
okay in the room M
two mic one in the
room Podium
mic and Mike yes because m is still sick
so
sorry no
no
Mike
two Mike
one
mik
three
what
I
watch
then
why
right
now
me
minut
wa
I'm sorry my hand is wet because
watch
col like the
p
fore
for
h
yeah okay no just checking that this uh
this is on morning everyone uh we're
gonna get started so please take your
seats and if you're having breakfast
just uh quietly uh welcome back um happy
to see uh to see all of you here we've
waited a little bit uh expecting that
some of you would be late because of the
snow uh a few uh reminders with respect
to what we said yesterday so first if
you have questions um there's the zulip
chat the the QR code will be up you can
ask around uh most of you are already
signed up uh we'll share the slides of
the talks uh on zip and on the website
we'll actually put them on on the
website and then uh it will be shared on
Z lip and uh if you have questions
during the talk please
uh do stand up and go to the uh to the
mics so that the questions can be
recorded for YouTube and for uh future
uh future use who want to to listen to
this so without F further Ado we're
going to start today with uh the second
day on gonets and Kia is going to be the
chair of this second day on the theory
of gonets uh so Kia is a postdoc here at
Mila with with Yoshua and uh he focuses
on probalistic inference algorithms uh
for structured lat and variable um and
is uh interested in applications in
Vision to vision and language uh Kia the
floor is
yours thank you and I will proceed
straight to introducing our first
Speaker who is yosua benju he may not
need an introduction but I will remind
you that Yoshua is professor at
University de monreal scientific
director of Mila and among many other
honors
a fellow of the Royal Society and a
recipient of the teing award for his
contributions to deep learning lately he
is also focusing on making sure that
artificial intelligence has a positive
impact on the future of humanity and he
will tell us now about why jets are
interesting thank you Kia thank you
Victor um
so okay
yes that was the first paper uh Europe
21 um
and it
happened after not so much time I forgot
exactly maybe just a few months uh that
we stumbled on um some of the
early uh exciting properties of these uh
that I'm going to say a few words about
but of course you'll hear a lot more
later today I'm sure Emanuel will be a
good
intro
um as far as I'm concerned maybe the
most important
property of gfl Nets is that they
are stochastic policies that generate
objects let's call them
x with some probability distribution and
when the training objective and there
are many choices is minimized they will
be sampling these objects with
probability proportional to a reward
function R ofx so
whereas generative models are typically
trained to imitate a given distribution
specified by a data set gfl Nets are
generative models that will learn to
sample when provided with an ear
normalized distribution function or a
reward function or an energy function
it's all the
same um so they solve a different
problem than the typical generative
models and of course we use the word
reward
because a lot of the ideas uh and that's
to emanuel's credit and um really came
from uh analogies with existing
reinforcement learning methods so this
was um a paper led by Emanuel
um and uh Mo and Maxim played uh an
important role especially in the
experiments um and uh this was kind of
co-led by doina and
myself all right so why uh just a few
months after the paper did I write in my
blog I have rarely been as enthusiastic
about a new research
Direction so I'm going to try to focus
on this maybe
Depending on time go a little bit deeper
on some of these
things um so the the first
angle came because we were working on
trying
to design new molecules that would have
certain characteristics certain
properties that we could
um put in the reward function so we
wanted to find molecules that had high
value of this reward function and
initially we played with just um a
standard reinforcement learning methods
and and Maxim had initiated that almost
a year
before but we found
that standard reinforcement learning and
this is not like a new thing we
discovered it was well known tends
to um lack in the diversity of solutions
that it find in fact the optimal
um reward maximizing policy is going to
generate a single object that has the
maximum
reward in uh scientific discovery for
example for drug discovery which was the
thing we were thinking about you really
want to have a diversity of solutions
and there's a number of good reasons why
you want that the reward function we're
using is not the true one that we care
about it's a proxy it's an approximation
maybe it's been trained from data
and so it could be wrong and so we don't
want to put all our eggs in the same
basket so diversity of the solutions was
really the initial
motivation and there were some existing
methods in reinforcement learning based
on adding entropy regularization to
reinforcement learning methods but they
they had some issues that I'll mention
um that made them not quite what we
wanted for the problem of
generating um
molecules now as we developed the ideas
that led to the the first version of the
gfl net um something really important
done me is that we we were um doing
something quite different in nature in
the way that we train these neural Nets
than the typical neural Nets so the
typical neural Nets trained by maximum
lud
um you have an
objective and
um you just agreed to descent on
it
um but the sort of problem we're trying
to solve with Gess
has
uh uh an intractable objective because
it involves for example the
normalization constant of the reward
function that is intractable we can't
compute gradients through that
intractable quantity that has an
exponential number of
terms but what's going on in gfl Nets in
a way that's you know we got the
inspiration from this from temporal
difference methods is that instead of
directly optimizing for the thing we
want like the log lik or
something um we reformulate the problem
into a set of
constraints such
that when these constraints are
satisfied we have what we want now
there's a catch the number of
constraints is exponentially large we
can't possibly visit all of
them but this is like a new kind of
objective function um that if minimized
in
expectation over choices of uh these
constraints has the right properties so
the right properties is I said is that
we are going to be sampling these
objects proportionally to the reward
function
which means from the target distribution
we're looking
for so so that's that's very interesting
um and the Bellman equation and
reinforcement learning has actually
similar structure we take the local
Bellman constraint and then we write
like a squared error loss that is what
people will use in U TD Lambda for
example but we we brought that to a
different kind of problem of
proportionately to a distribution and in
addition to sampling actually the
methods we developed were also
marginalizing meaning Computing these
normalization constant and then we found
other sort of marginalization so
marginalization means
summing uh some quantity Where the sum
is usually intractable so we can't just
do the sum we have to use some other
trick so the trick is we train some M
net or some scaler in the case of the
partition function that um if we
minimize the objective computes the
right
sums so so these um intractable sampling
and intractable marginalization
abilities of gonet when they minimize
their objective is something that got me
really really excited because
for about two decades I had realized
that essentially all the good things we
want to do in machine learning can be
solved if we can do marginalization and
sampling in cases that are
intractable so where it's not easy to do
because we are dealing
with um two high dimensional spaces and
this is exactly the job that Monte Carlo
Mark of chain methods are in principle
solving but I'll come back to you know
they are they have some problems they
actually
uh would solve the problem with
exponential
computation um and when you have finite
amount of computation they end up
finding solutions that don't have enough
diversity which was the thing we started
with and I'll try to explain why we're
getting more diversity with gonets than
with
mcmc MC the gonets then it took us a
while to figure out uh actually happen
to be connected to other uh Mach machine
learning methods for dealing with
intractable uh
inference and these are the variational
methods and we we wrote a
paper um that came out at I clear this
year that that explains this and how
they're related to these variational
methods in fact you can think of gonet
as a variational method where we don't
use the kale Divergence as the you know
to define the objective but something
else that has really nice proper
properties um again that help us with
the diversity question so the
typical pullback leer based um
variational methods which are the ones
that have been studied in the
literature like mcmc methods suffer in
you know typically finding one or a few
modes of the distribution but uh getting
stuck there and mcmc methods also get
stuck in the same
way so yeah um there was another reason
why I thought this was very important I
had been working with my group and
collaborators
for um many
years on Bridging the Gap to uh human
intelligence um with this notion that
current neural Nets do well with system
one abilities like
intuition but not so well well in system
two abilities which have to do with
reasoning and their
uncertainty we do a better job and when
I you know started playing with chat GPT
the first thing I tried was like make it
solve some of simple reasoning
tasks and it failed
um so what we need to solve system two
is according to me uh these reasoning
and uncertainty capabilities and and
that's what the probabilistic inference
abilities of um gflow Nets or their
descendants which have yet to be uh
invented um can
do so um yeah that's in summary why I
was so
excited
um let me now go quickly through some
elements maybe to clarify the abstract
things I've been saying and and you'll
see a lot more depth in in the coming uh
talks I
assume
so think of um neural net that will
sequentially generate a compositional
object and what we started with as
compositional objects are graphs so you
can generate a graph by generating one
Edge at a time picking a new Edge to add
to an existing graph that has been
partially constructed so the the ne net
decides at each step some action that
makes us move towards the completion of
the task of sampling the object we care
about and you know in the language of
reinforcement learning we're just
learning this
policy um that decides what to do at
each step and then at some point chooses
a special action that says we're done we
have the object we want to uh
sample and and then we're going to get a
reward okay
so so these neural Nets take at each
step the currently partially constructed
object like a graph like in the figure
say here that has these three nodes and
two edges and it chooses the next action
like adding a new Edge that connects a
new node four to an existing node
two okay so so we're going to learn
these policies um which we denote PF for
forward policy which move the state in
the reinforcement learning sense which
is a partial construction to um to the
next state until we end up in a special
terminal state that says oh we're done
we have the object we
want and one way to analyze
this that really helps develop the
intuition so why it's hard and what are
we trying to actually do is uh you know
this
figure that Manuel managed to to do some
trickery um where you see the little
blue things are like uh um drops of
water that are flowing in this direct to
the cyclic graph so what is this direct
to the cyclic graph well it
shows um the different states
corresponding to partial constructions
it shows that we're going to start with
an initial State as zero for example
like an empty graph and it shows that at
each State we have a choice of different
actions that bring you to a New
State and there are also special states
which mean we're done when we choose a
special action here like there's a t for
terminal
action and of course here it's a cartoon
graph the real uh dags that we care
about are exponentially large first of
all the number of states is
exponentially
large um and the number of trajectories
in you know to construct these things
are uh is also exponentially large and
the thing that makes things complicated
is that it's it's a dag it's not a tree
which means that there are many ways to
land in the same state and and that is a
thing that previous work in
reinforcement learning could couldn't
deal
with so in the original paper we had a
first uh uh
constraint that had the property that
went
satisfied the
policy defined with uh uh the output of
the new net would sample um as we wanted
so proportionally to the reward function
and the constraint had to do with you
know looking at this dag and saying for
each state look at all the water coming
in and all the water coming out and they
have to be the same it's kind of
conservation of flow
um and then we can turn that constraint
into a loss by taking like the log on
both sides and uh taking the difference
and squaring and minimizing making sure
that these these losses are minimized
everywhere at least um you know
According to some training
distribution um gives us what we want
that we going to sample the objects with
the right probability which is the
reward function normalized and of course
we can't compute that normalization
constant and and and it's intractable to
even
sample okay and one of the key
ingredients here is that we can
choose the distribution of trajectories
in this graph um that we're going to be
using to uh train the G Net and that
makes gfl Nets very special in terms of
reinforcement learning in the sense that
you know we call them offline learning
because
the um configurations or the
trajectories that we train on don't have
to be the same or coming from the same
distribution as what the current policy
has as a as a as a distribution so at
any point the new net defines a
distribution over trajectories because
at each step you choose to go you know
left right I mean this next state or
that next state um but that distribution
is problematic because if it
only uh you know likes some particular
kind of trajectories and there are
others that is missing it kind of
never uh gets to see those good
trajectories that it's
missing and so it never reduces the loss
at those points that it doesn't visit
and that's the problem with um the you
know existing variational methods but
with G Nets we're able to train on any
distribution of trajectory so long it
has not uh you know it has it puts Mass
everywhere and so if we have some clues
about where the missing modes could be
we can use that in practice one of the
tricks we use is uh we take the current
policy and we consider a tempered
version that has like a higher
temperature so it explores more and so
so that seems to work but one of the
open problems is can we do better than
that so why is it that the mcmc methods
aren't that great uh I mean they're
great for a lot of problems I mean like
a large part of physics and chemistry
relies on these methods but but they
have an issue as I said in terms of
diversity they tend to
find um just a few modes that are easy
to find so the way that mcmc methods
work is by taking a current candidate
solution and then making stochastic
moves in the neighborhood of that
solution um where most of the time you
would try to make it better but
sometimes you allow to make it slightly
worse in terms of the reward
function and so the problem with that is
because it in order to move from one
mode one region where the re the reward
is high to another mode you have to go
through a number of
steps in
which the mcmc procedure you know
doesn't want to go you know it has a low
probability of picking these U steps
moving away from the currently good
Solutions and if you need a long
sequence of of small steps to go from
one mode to another it becomes
exponentially unlikely that you'll find
a way from one mod to the other and so
they tend to get stuck with the modes
that are easy to find by just random
perturbations and then going down um I
mean going up in the reward function or
going down in
energy
um so why would
you how could you possibly do better
right it looks like one so that's that's
part of like what really got me excited
very quickly about gonets which is I
thought exactly 10 years ago after
playing with all kinds of mcmc methods
for training machine learning
systems that it was impossible that we
couldn't
find those modes that were hard to find
and away from the ones we have already
had
but that's using traditional mcmc
methods that only that that don't take
advantage of the knowledge that is being
acquired As you move around in that
space trying different things but
machine learning methods have this
ability not always but when you know
they're successful to generalize meaning
for example in the like uh Toy scenario
here that if if the learner so now we're
learning right we're taking advantage of
the information we're Gathering as we
try things if we've tried a bunch of
things and we found these three regions
where the reward is
high it may give us clues about other
places far from those we've seen that
may also have a high reward like you
know the missing grid corner here looks
like a good place to
look and indeed I think
recently uh Alex did experiments which I
thought wouldn't work but actually
similar to this and and the gonet
discovers these
modes so so that's why I got excited
that machine learning generalization
abilities could come to the rescue to
solve or to make progress on these
apparently intractable problem problems
in probabilistic
inference um another Advantage which is
more practical is that once we train our
gfl net once we trained our neural net
it can generate samples very quickly
whereas mcmc methods need to go through
you know very long chain or small
steps um which potentially could take
exponential time before they visit the
things we
want um and this ability to generalize
across modes when
sampling carries to the problem of
marginalization which is summing overall
the
modes so actually I have a little bit of
math if if I
can um so so I'm going to focus on the
problem
of uh
marginalization first I'm going to show
you that neets already do things like
like this but not quite what we want
here so if you train a new net with
squared error laws so the new net here
um estimates the is s ofx right it's
it's trying to estimate that
sum um of the expected
reward in the context X we're trying to
sum over values of Y and we're given a
sampler p y given X nice so if we if we
Define a loss like the squared loss here
for anual net s hat and we minimize this
in expectation over the sampler p y
given X it's very very easy to show that
you recover the right thing expected
value of y given X it's like machine
learning 101
regression okay problem is we don't know
that sampler p y given X so we just have
the integrant the summon the thing uh
like reward of x Y and we don't know how
to sample
it and so the idea here with gonet style
solution is going is going to say aha we
don't know how to sample and we don't
know how to marginalize to compute that
sum but let's solve both problems at
once so we're g
to learn two things we're going to learn
a sampler which here I wrote like P hat
of Y given X and we're going to learn
the marginalize S hat so s s hat is
approximating the sum we want at the top
and Pad is approximating the normalized
reward distribution which is the
sampler okay
and um then you can do like trivial
algebra where you say Okay so the
sampler Pi y given X should be equal to
the reward normalized where s is the sum
remember and we can take that equation
and take s which is in the denominator
put it on the left hand side so we get
the third
equation and that's a constraint that's
the constraints I've been talking about
so now take the log on both sides put
the square I mean take the difference so
log of the product minus log of R and
it's trivial to show that when we get
that loss to zero over all XY
pairs this constraint is satisfied and
it's also trival to show that once the
constraint is satisfied for every XY
pair you get you get the the property
that you want the simpler is the right
one and the moizer is the right one so
so that's really what we're exploiting
with
gonet and I think I will stop here thank
you
you have an exam
after
question
yep there are no questions let's thank
yosua again for this
introduction and and now I'd like to
introduce Emanuel Benjo who will give us
the introduction the first technical
introduction to Jet Emanuel is ml
scientist at Valance Formerly Known as
recursion where he does research on the
union of jets and Drug
Discovery thanks Kia
um for the record uh recursion absorb
veence not the other way around so
veence is part of
recursion no worries um so yeah you've
heard from plan from yosua and I will be
repeating some of the stuff but
hopefully would do different perspective
and also petition is great um to
learn so um I'll start again with here
you go I think by now you've heard what
A gonet is um I love this slide because
sometimes people come to me and they're
like so jonet that's what kind of
Architecture is that um I guess we did
not choose the name optimally it's not a
neur
architecture but you've heard that
already um so
that's generative framework where
initially we designed it to sample
combinatorial objects uh it's still used
a lot for that but um we can now do
continuous things and I think you're
going to hear about that later today um
and you know what are the typical Comal
objects molecules that's where we got
started with G flets um but also
proteins
language uh asan networks all sorts of
things
um
and
um yeah I guess I'll I'll tell you more
about how we came to that um again as
Yos
mentioned during the pandemic we kind of
threw some reinforcement learning at
coid uh hoping to find cool things we
did not find a
antiviral but we did find new algorithms
and that was very fun and the context
setting was basically we doing search
with re enforcement learning we had some
reward function some way to quantify how
good a
particular yes particular uh molecule
was but of course that reward function
was extremely noisy in particular those
familiar with the the context we're
using docking just some kind of uh low
resolution physical simulation of how
let's say a molecule a small molecule
and a protein interact and how much
energy is between them um that's of
course very noisy because it's only an
approximation of physics um and that
meant that you can kind of easily fool
that reward function and and lots of
candidates looked good
um but you know even though lots of
candidates look good it's still a kind
of needle and a hyack problem you just
have lots of needle and your hstack is
10 to the uh big number and you know uh
finding really different uh kinds of
molecules that all maybe were
interesting according to that reward was
pretty hard so you know hopefully you
you find that uh set of solutions and
you send them to your wet lab and you
get more data to kind of bootstrap from
um but the big question is what do you
want to send and the traditional way
that people have done this in all sorts
of context is apply some ml generate a
batch of candidates and then kind of
manually or
turistic uh pick the best uh including
some Notions of diversity and that could
be like uh for molecules based on
scaffolds but uh all sorts of things you
may want to cover your state space
intelligently um but this is all
handcrafting we would like not to have
to do that um so you know the motivation
is what what's a good technique that
finds something diverse by uh
construction and you know why is
diversity important I think yosu has
given some pretty convincing arguments I
have more um in organic
chemistry biology um physics in general
but all sorts of
domains um as I mentioned the proxies
the reward functions that we have are
very very imprecise they're sometimes
models of models of models um and so
they can only get you so far right
you're seeing on the right here this
this nice animation of of docking uh a l
at a more kind of refined level here um
and and that's that's really cute and
it's really helpful for someone to
understand what's going on when they're
trying to understand a molecule but it's
really an approximation uh the real
world is more complicated right this
protein might be living in a cell and
being jiggled around by many other
processes
right so um again this this nice for
mode picture that I think you're going
to see a lot
um we want to cast a really wide net you
know if only one of these modes is
actually correct we'd really like uh to
have one candidate in each of these
modes not just for let's say in the same
mode if we're only allowed for picks in
reality of course the the state space
the reward space is is way more complex
you don't have these nice uh easily
separable modes probably have much worse
um so diversity is is important there
kind of by
construction
um another reason I think it's important
that I'm actually working on with other
people is
um we know that new networks can
generalize pretty
well um but that heavily depends on what
data they're trained
on
and as
uh We've mentioned you
know the more kind of modes you see the
more combinations of different features
you see
um you would think that a model would
want to go to this different mode
right that's kind of a nice property of
generalization and a nice property of
getting an energy based model to to to
go everywhere um and the neat feature of
gfets is that they have this kind of by
constr ction right they as they learn
about their reward in their state space
um they induce their own training
distribution because typically we train
them on policy or on policy adjacent
with some exploration stuff um and so as
Chief has learned they kind of build
their own really nice training
distribution which I believe kind of uh
takes fully advantage of the
generalization capabilities of neur
Networks
that's another argument for diversity um
you've heard about RL and mcmc yesterday
um you know can totally use them to
solve these kinds of problems um so for
example for Dr Discovery from molecular
design again we have an mdp right we
have actions and rewards um but exp
verion is NRL is very complex topic it's
really hard and in practice when we
apply our all methods we do things see
problems with diversity um as has been
mentioned and same with
mcmc um mode mixing a hard problem
right in in kind of expectation in the
limit uh mcmc gives you the right
solution but you don't want to have to
wait
forever um and we can also use the usual
J generative models
um the the kind of downside of this
class of models usually although they
are you know of course extensions but
the the main ones that you've heard a
lot about like uh diff Fusion models are
are typically based really on um having
a kind of data set of positive samples
right so I show you million images of
cats get really good at generating cats
um but for something like like molecules
because we have this scaler reward
instead of this yes this is a cat or yes
this is a dog um there there's one
information in that scaler or those
scalers uh if you're doing
multiobjective optimization and we don't
want to waste that information it's
really uh useful
information
so going to do uh some reward portional
model um and of course we want to avoid
doing
mcmc so uh you've seen this before I
think yesterday you see it again during
your practical sessions um
kind of intro combinatorial objects is
of course something like smiley faces
where you pick am I gon to choose the
eyebrow like this or the smile like this
um and the really important thing to
notice is that there are many ways to
build one given face right so for this
evil smiling face
um there's a number of trajectories that
lead to it and it's very important to
account for
that
um again we are in a setting where we
assume that we have some kind of reward
or energy function um and what we're
going to do is use that reward
to associate a flow with each state in
particular for the terminal
States um we're going to think of them
as syncs you can absorb all this flow
and the initial State here on the left
you can think of it as the unique Source
in your network right and so we end up
with this Network the very important
part to kind of get the right properties
that we want that you want all your flow
to be conserved everywhere um so for
example here right you get three units
of flow kind of flowing into that state
um and here for example this
intermediate state only has one unit and
you'll see that if I pause the right
moment um you'll see that it's kind of
split in two because that state has two
parents um and then we combine again
here and then we combine again
here so you can do that for all your
States um and you end up with a flow
Network that you can use to sample fixes
so how do we do that we Define this
policy that will write PF which if
you're in a some State s to decide which
state to pick next
stastically um you assign a probability
to each transition that is proportional
to the edge flow right so here for a
particular Edge we take the the flow on
that edge and divide by all the other
flows outgoing from that
Noe and the really neat thing is
mentioned uh this gives us a anter of
model
oops
um the the the
ratio here that that we're choosing
induces a really nice distribution where
if all the flows are are preserved of
course the probity of sampling some
particular state is going to be
proportional to the flow that's going
into
it um and then that's of course
extremely useful
um May El up there again to see if there
are
questions no question so I'm assuming
everyone here
understands great yeah so you know R
this where smiley faces we can do that
for molecules um here's a really cartoon
environment but in reality we'd have a
lot more things um and so if we have a
lot more things we can't actually you
know instantiate this flow Network in
memory it wouldn't fit um so we have to
use function approximation and we're
going to do just that um typically you
know we use new networks but you can use
anything uh for example for molecules we
can use grafal
networks and what we're going to do or
rather the first thing that we did uh in
the first G paper was to estimate Edge
flows right so you have some Edge um and
typically the paration we would use is
kind of uh give a description of that
state as an input to the function and
that function would output a number of
scalers um one per potential next
state um you might see in the G papers
they're often referred to as actions
that is again again some kind of
historical
uh you know accident I want to say uh
because we kind of inherited all the RL
terminology while thinking about these
things um it's pretty common in
reinforcement learning to think of I'm
at a state I can take some actions here
the actions are like go to next state
but you can think of them here for
example as one action being add this new
fragment to this existing
molecule and
so see it's already but hopefully seeing
it again will
help um one way to encode this desire to
train this function proximator is to
think of the constraints that we want
right so given a state we want all the
flow that's coming into it to be equal
to all the flow that's coming out of
it um and then for terminal States in
particular um
we are assuming that there are sync
States and so we want all the flow that
goes into them to be equal to the reward
again we're assuming here the reward is
given
um the nice thing is that once again if
the those conditions are satisfied and
we're sampling trajectories from this
policy that we've defined then it's
guaranteed that we sample from the right
distribution so of course the first
reflex is to turn these equations into a
me squ error uh and this is kind of
exactly what t z is doing um actually
for a large enough State space that
would be a terrible idea um so going to
go back a bit here you'll notice that um
at the root right the initial State
actually contains a lot of flow in fact
you might have noticed in the slides I
don't think has been very explicitly
mentioned but what you actually recover
is that the flow of the initial state is
actually equal to the partition function
which is the sum of all rewards in your
network um and the bigger network is the
bigger State spaces the bigger this
quantity is going to be right so if you
have 10 to the 60 objects um that you
possible object that you're constructing
and you know uh for a lot of objects
this reward is something non zero the
value of Z might be extremely
large so if you're taking mean squared
errors here um GNA have a bad time
because your network will have much
larger losses for the early States
because they have a lot more flow and uh
will kind of maybe be really good in
some sense predicting their flow but
really bad at predicting the flow of
terminal objects because the losses
there will be extremely
small so what we do in instead and I
think what you'll notice we do for
basically all the um gonet objectives is
we operate on a log
scale and the utility of doing that is
that now the the the value of a mean
squared error on a log scale will be
kind of
uh invariant to the scale of the flow
that you're mod right so close to the
the leaves close to the terminal
States
um the the the difference in log between
two predictions that are wrong will kind
of have uh as significant magnitude than
the loss on the early States
um and that it turns out is is pretty
important to make the whole thing work
um so this this first objective we call
it flow matching and I
think yes there you go
and um know there's some interesting
things about this objective first of all
uh if you do it on the log scale it's
not that bad if you make your anal
Network output legits uh then these two
operations are are log sux operations
which can be numerically stable and in
addition you can also use an Epsilon uh
value that you would add to both terms
to kind of stabilize learning here
um actually your Epsilon term here can
do more than just stabilize things um it
can
actually you know as I was
mentioning um give a preference to the
the model to ignore some of the very
lowf flow objects right so
um U earlier I was I was saying if you
have uh let's say lots of very small
flows and you're doing a linear mean
squared error the mean squ error will be
tiny um whereas if you're doing on a log
scale be same everywhere if you'd add an
Epsilon after bringing these terms into
a linear scale um if the flows are
really small the rewards are really
small in the case of out flows um then
the Epsilon will kind of bring back
again this mean squ area to be really
small so in flow matching that can
actually be used to to help the model
ignore lower reward States
um second point
is uh so for those familiar with tempal
difference methods you might be
wondering why are we you know using the
same
network in the Target and why is it not
detached
um it might be weird to
uh
to to think of it from an RL perspective
because uh we're so used to kind of
thinking of maybe fitted GE iteration
and stuff like that but here we're doing
something pretty different first of all
uh maybe uh your mdp is deterministic
right so if you think about um the
double sampling issue that Q learning
has you wouldn't have it here because
well you always have the same sample uh
when taking a
transition um and then I think maybe
it's not quite correct to think about it
in terms of RL and temporal difference
because really we're just satisfying
constraints um and and these kind of
locally must make sense and also
globally make sense on top of that
you're using in network which will
generalize right so it makes sense for
kind of both sides of the equation to
inform each other in terms of
loss
um
so once you have these
things
um
usually you know I think most people
will train a gonet online on policy um
you'll hear later today and I think
tomorrow about more of training G Nets
that will do some some exploration or
some offline training on
samples
um but the basic training Loop is uh
very online RL right so you start the
initial State you start the smiley face
example um with an empty face and you
take actions to to build an object and
Sample a trajectory using the policy
that you've constructed and then once
the agent says okay I'm done stop uh
reive the reward and then we collect a
bunch of these trajectories and apply
the flow matching objective along that
trajectory
um
because I was mentioning uh you know
this is like the the basic thing to do
there are lots of Tricks here of course
but um
basically
uh yeah one thing I didn't mention of
course but I think yosha mentioned is
that these objectives are off policy
objectives right um as long as you have
a cover of State space you don't need to
be following your policy to uh learn the
correct uh values and that means that if
you have a data set of trajectories or
data set of samples um that can be used
to train your model um there's lots of
ways and um you'll hear about this more
but the basic way is you know you start
with some high reward objects and you
kind of bias the mini batch of your
model to see more of these objects
um of course doing that will induce some
trade-offs so if you show lots of high
reward objects uh to your model you
might think oh there is you know problem
solved I already kind of found all the
interesting things and it might not
learn to explore properly so of course
another kind of off policy you can do is
exploration uh methods there's lots of
them and the kind of basic one that
we've been doing but of course we should
be doing better is this Epsilon online
trick that I think people doing Q
learning and varant are very familiar
with where you basically follow your
policy but with some small Epsilon
chance take a random
action
um this this you know Works H but of
course we can do better
so of course one downside of the flow
matching objective that I just talked
about is that it's very local uh what do
we mean by
that um it only
considers you know a single state in
some sense and learns around it so the
state won't be very informed by the
trajectory that it's in or the the the
reward that was part of the trajectory
it was in um this has some advantages
but then at the same time it makes
learning very slow because the the
temporal credit assignment has to kind
of propagate slow from the reward at the
end of the terminal States back to the
initial
States another downside of flow matching
is that it's very
expensive um the main reason is because
of these sums so as I mentioned earlier
the typical parameterization of a gflow
net uh that uses these Edge flow
predictions is you train NE Network and
this new Network's input is actually the
initial well not the initial state but
the the first state on this Edge right
um and let's say that you know this
state has 100 uh
children so 100 actions um you'll simply
output a 100 numbers 100 logits for that
particular
State um sorry yeah so for for the
outflow that's not a problem right um
you have you have one state and and you
just output 100 kind of jits um for the
incoming flow though uh it's a bit more
complicated right so you'll notice here
s is the inputs is on the left hand side
but here s is kind of one of the outputs
and to take the sum here you actually
have to enumerate all the parents of
that state s not only do you have to
enumerate them if there's 100 parents
you have to do 100 forward passes uh of
your model to get the edge flow for that
particular Edge um and you know hundred
is not that bad but in some cases if
you're doing molecular design on the
atom level uh or you're doing natural
language uh in in some funky way um you
can end up with an enormous number of of
parents and that's just not
scalable
um and so
yes um that's
expensive as I mentioned you know this
is related to boost trapping in
reinforcement learning um boost trapping
has a lot of issues
um uh there there can be drift right
because you're you're not drift sorry
bias that induces drift because you're
kind of trusting the prediction of what
happens in the next states that your
model is doing uh and that can lead to a
lot of bias um and make your model take
a very long time to
learn um so today you'll hear about much
better variants uh that are more
efficient H but also you know less bias
and more
stable you also hear about better
parametrizations so once again the the
parametrization here is on the edge flow
um but all you need is is some way of
getting flows um and you can get that
indirectly by multiplying things uh but
no spoilers you you'll hear about
that and finally um of course as with
any method lots of tricks can help um
some from reinforcement learning of
course uh replay buffers in in various
ways can help
um uh Target networks that you know are
some kind of moving average or or
um kind of old version of your model can
help stabilize sampling or just
learning um you'll also hear about
various forms of intrinsic rewards uh
that may help with learning stability or
exploration um you can
also uh grab tricks from mcmc um there's
a very recent paper that I'm on where
kind of combine gats and mcmc
uh in a very simple way where you kind
of start a trajectory with jonet lands
somewhere and because gonet is diverse
you kind of get that diversity for free
but then you can use mcmc to do some
kind of local refinement of your reward
and we know that's going to work because
mcmc is is very good at um
exploration exploring locally within a
mode um you'll hear a lot about
temperature as well um it's very common
that uh if you kind of take some some
random reward function and some random
setting um the scale of it will be a bit
wrong right so for example uh if in your
state space you have a million objects
um and almost all of them have like 0.
five reward and 10 have one reward
um the total mass of the 0 five reward
object still half a million right and so
the probability of sampling those will
be really high as Le trick of course to
kind of lower the probability of those
uh5 reward objects increase the reward
of the one reward objects is to use the
temperature um so one thing that we've
been doing that you'll see again in
papers is just raise the reward to some
exponent beta usually that beta is some
hyperparameter uh but it can also be uh
part of the input we can learn
temperature conditional models but it's
Al also something that can be scheduled
during
training um other trick that you'll hear
about
uh I won't go too much into it but you
can uh use data sets and Maxum
likelihood to do interesting
things um yeah so thank you for
listening and I think I'll take
questions and then Kia will tell you
more about these new objectives that we
have
nice talk Emanuel uh you motivated like
uh G flets and then compared it with TL
at the beginning right and one of the
challenges you mentioned was like
exploration in RL it wasn't clear to me
how G flets could uh Explore More State
space and then gather more data like
could you yeah um maybe let me go back
to well you know one of the caveats of
RL is that
um at least let's say you're doing soft
ke learning which is like nice
maxent uh method you should get for free
some proportionality but that
proportionality is a bit pathological if
there are end paths
to this state then the probability of
sampling
it kind
of yeah the probably assling it will be
something like number of fats times the
reward proportional to that um you know
for smiley faces is not that bad you
only have like six paths to hear but for
a molecule uh that has you
know 50 atoms you have an unfathomable
number
ofs um and and this bias will lead these
methods to do weird things um another
Advantage if you compare to just like
even more traditional gdl is that um
some some gdl methal might find one mode
and be kind of happy with it because
well it's find a pretty optimal policy
um and maybe we can get it to explore
but like it takes a while before the
policy learns oh I can also go there uh
in contrast wants to do that by
construction there's no built-in
exploration mechanism and it wants to
spread the property Mass everywhere and
that kind of naturally makes it
explore um I don't know if that contrast
them well yeah uh also like um do you
assume like you know like what molecule
fits with what other molecule because if
you don't know then you might have to
explore all combinations to decide like
which ones are fit well which ones don't
and then it kind of like falls down to
the same exploration problem right well
you have to
assume
that your reward contains some
information and that some of this
information can be captured by Network
right so either the reward itself right
so a typical scenario is uh you sent 100
molecules to the lab and you get some
reading out of them then you train uh
you'll let work random forest or
whatever uh on those 100 data points and
that gives you some predictions and then
you can feed in new molecules to that
new network get new results and you use
that as your reward function then what
you do is is bootstrap from that so you
train a generative model you get maybe
10 new molecules send them to the wet
lab and then you kind of grow your data
set
um but you have to trust that there's
some information in there so so that
this model of reward that you're Capt
that you're training captures something
and then that model has to also have
structure so that the gfl net that
you're training to you know MCH reward
function can also have some structure um
otherwise of course it's kind of
hopeless yeah also I was thinking of
distributional LL like U I mean um like
what special about uh sampling according
to rewards question a and two can we do
this with distributional LL um get much
more with that as compared to gfet like
any thoughts on that U let me start with
distribution RL
um distribution RL is about a
parameterization of the value function
it's kind of fundamentally the same
algorithm you're
learning to you know you're learning the
value function of the optimal policy
it's just that in distribution LL
instead of learning the expectation you
learn
some distributional form of the value
function uh of the the random variable
that the expectation is modeling um but
you're still learning the same function
uh in ginet you're learning an entire
object entire different object entirely
which is about you know energy based
style
model um can you you could sorry you
could potentially sample uh actions once
you have the distribution or value
function the value of the state you can
potentially sample actions using any of
the uh metrics right not just expected
value maybe you would want to sample
like um like quartiles based actions or
things like that which kind of gives you
like diverse policies essentially
right
uh I not sure that's correct but I'm not
a distributional RL expert one thing I
do know is distribution will give you
something like risk or risk policies
because you can look at the variance
let's say of the value prediction of
different actions and pick the one
that's high W and low variance but I
don't know
about using that for diversity because
uh the best diversity you'd get is
diversity of rewards so you could do the
inverse of risk RSE you can do
risk-seeking right you pick the action
that has the most variance um but then
that just means you might sample low
reward
actions um here you can you know still
sample High reward uh objects is just
because of the
smoothness
um
you you have this diversity by
default I
don't hi I have a very naive question
okay so I specialize in physics and I'm
not an expert in this field but um in
physics when we look at flows you know
and nature we also can have back flows
so I'm wondering why are all your like
transfer of information in one specific
Direction yeah I guess here we're just
using flow as a very convenient analogy
yeah um not too familiar with what a
backflow might be
um I
think so so here we kind of design these
flow networks to be asy DS and that's
very convenient because then we don't
have to think about cases um you could
actually have Cycles in here yeah that's
what I'm thinking yeah
um it would use some problems but I we
think we can fix those problems without
too much difficulty
um I think for me it just seems that
you're you would add another dimension
like you would add more exploration so
it would might be
logic yeah I I'm curious to know what a
backflow is but maybe come see me at the
break thanks
uh thanks Emanuel for the great talk so
I just wanted to go back to the slide
that you were describing how we can
train uh jet offline uh so you mentioned
that uh maybe we can initiate the
samples that have high rewards but what
if we don't have access to that you know
um harb samples yeah so uh something
that works fairly well is a replay
buffer where you only keep your top end
samples right right and then that that
kind of counts as uh leveraging a data
set is just your data set is
dynamic that works pretty well but then
there is this trade-off sometimes of if
you too to greedy to high reward with
the data that you show your model then
okay yeah but so what if okay so I
understand that you know replay buffer
actually keeps the um you can have some
sort of a priority in your replay buffer
and keep the samples High Reps but what
if we actually you know like there's a
scenario that um we cannot assign
rewards to those trajectories um and
maybe you can do some sort of uh
clustering and just you know figure out
what samples have more values to the
task that you are trying to
solell um are you saying if you don't
even have a word function what can you
do yeah okay so I mean uh we
have some results where if you have a
data set you can do energy based thing
basically and uh learn the energy
function as you're training your
sampler that that's totally fair game um
you were talking about clusters maybe
you could if you don't have a data set
but you have some notion of distance
between samples you could use that
distance
information clustering information to
build an energy function or W function I
think that would also be fair game um as
long as it's consistent with the problem
you're solving
yeah should should be fine okay thank
you so yes I had a similar question
related to the one before um like why
are you what are the reasons of using
flow instead of weights for example no
it's like to apply the condition that
the input has equal the output of flow
or or is there any other reason like for
using flow instead of Weights you
know I mean the the the flow is just
metaphor yeah um there's there's not a
the physical interpretation here it's
really just a convenient way to to think
about maybe or explain the concept yeah
I was like curious about it you know
because usually we see like weights in
the neural networks right well so but
you are defining like the ratio flow
that could be also like the same concept
no so like you know this this
is this is a a flow network but not a NE
Network right yeah um we never actually
see this graph anywhere like we don't
instantiate it in the program it's only
implicit in the fact that we have an
agent that can like build faces right
okay so what what the Neal Network sees
let's say is like a face and it makes
predictions about that face particular
here for the the empty face it makes six
predictions which kind of tell it which
action to pick which next phas to go
to yeah more reward than you know okay
okay
okay you think you
then a quick question regarding the
training you said this was done online I
wonder how this like does this mean that
for each for example given molecule
you're going to have like one online
learning pass or is there a way to like
Leverage the fact that different m
problems might have
similarities like aside from the reward
function uh TR I get your question so
like basically are we just like when you
learn online like this is it like one
sort of online
learning TK for each different molecule
you're trying to learn yeah so one thing
we assume is that the the reward
function is somewhat cheap to compute
and if it's not cheap like you have to
send something to wet
then you can train a proxy for
it they're always around that but they
all kind of in my opinion equivalent to
training a proxy for it and then yeah so
you're just seeing a molecule training
on it and then you kind of throw away
that data because you want to learn
about different modules so basically
like it's more the compute time than the
data you really want to go like one
example at a time or like one problem at
a time but you're going to just like I
don't know use as many compute Cycles as
possible and hopefully you're going to
like converge towards
distribution yeah that's correct okay
than thank you for the talk Emanuel so I
had a question concerning the structure
of the gonet like I was wondering what
is the advantage of um having many
trajectories that lead to the same
terminal States instead of of having a
tree for your gonus because like one one
helps to share information but this also
makes the problem more complex because
you have to learn more things yeah I
think that's actually interesting
research question um so there's two
things one
is um for something like a molecule or a
smiley face we could uh canonicalize the
order in which you build it right so we
could always choose the left eyebrow
first then choose the sorry the right
eyebrow first then the left eyebrow then
the mouth then we would have a treat say
um sometimes that's actually really hard
to do
uh for very symmetric
objects like molecules for example that
you Define atom by atom uh there's not a
good way to canonically build them such
that you'll end up with an mdp that's
always a
tree
um let's say you're you're building this
little triangle here um well actually I
don't know if that's a good example
but
um I think sorry I'm trying to think of
an example on the spot but like
um if you're building this ring
um here like a neat canonical form would
be you always have to start with the
oxygen and then the other carbon atoms
but like for more complex molecules
that's not always possible and you end
up with different versions of the same
thing depending on which of these carbon
atoms you start
with um and in the general case you
can't enforce well easily maybe you can
but it's a very complicated her istic
and complex masking but as far as I know
um in people in chemistry have been
thinking about this a lot for something
like Smiles it's really hard to build
kind of a unique sequence that
describes one
object um but another related question I
think for gonus in particular is that
something that we'll be discussed a bit
later is um there's implicitly here some
kind of backward allocations of the flow
here I kind of did some thing where
everything is equal but you could
possibly train a network to say no I
only want to care about one parent at a
time then you'd kind of end up with so
but I I don't know if anyone's
investigated that
properly yeah I have a good question
about the the concept of the flow
because I come from the oral background
so for me this kind of looks like just a
value function but your discount Factor
sets one I was wondering if you ever
experienced with oh if it's possible to
have this a discount Factor where your
your inflow is equal to like gamma of
your outflow like have this concept of
discounted flows if it even if it breaks
your training or not and would you even
be interested in going that path is
discounting even relevant in terms of
generating
data I want to say no but I think some
people have thought about this more
deeply than I uh so I'll redirect you to
that so come see me after thank
you hi thanks for the talk um I'm
curious if empirically you have any
observations regarding the number of
samples needed for training relative to
the number of terminal states in the
problem is there there any like relation
there or is it the number of samples to
like converge yeah uh it's really
problem dependent I guess these are not
cheap
methods um like training on the
simplified fragment environment
molecule uh it can take you know six
hours to start getting decent results
and like I've train model for days and
they still have not converged they're
still learning and discovering new
things um
but I think it's really going to be
problem depending
thanks probably last question make it
quick
maybe uh I was wondering uh there's this
assumption in in making the U
in composing uh the smiley face for
example uh there's no difference in uh
first doing the left eyebrow than the
right eyebrow so uh what if there was a
slight difference instead of U there
could be no difference assumption and
there could be a large difference in
which case we wouldn't have a that what
if there was a slight uh
difference yeah I mean this is the case
in like fragments um depending on uh say
you're doing chemical synthesis kind of
environments depending on the order in
which you do things you get different
results uh that that's true and there's
there's ways to handle that you just
have to represent your state the right
way so that when you give it as an input
to the network it knows that the
differences are there but
yeah very quickly what is the trade-off
in terms of how you split up your action
space so you could for instance have uh
maybe like just a very like a large
number of possible paths but with like
only a few actions so few parents or you
have a very complex action so you have
lots of parents but you have kind of
less States in your intermediate States
what is the kind of tradeoff in training
complexity that's a very good question
um and I think this deserves more study
because there are some cases where we've
done that experiment so let's say your
gener sequence and you only have like
four
tokens you could have four actions or
and generate one token or two or 16
actions during so you can think of all
the the lengths and if you do that
doesn't seem to be that much difference
which is
surprising um but in some other
environments where we're generating
graphs um the like the the way you you
give choices to the agent does seem to
matter um sometimes very negatively if
you're not careful um and I think that's
something that should be studied more in
reinforcement learning how to design an
mdp thank
you
no I've already been
introduced so I I don't introduce myself
again and can you see my screen okay yes
good here we are so you get to hear from
me about a lot of
math I hope everyone is very excited
about
this
so I will tell you about two different
training objectives for jlow Nets you
heard about flow matching and how
optimizing a flow matching objective at
every state in a jflow net leads to
getting a policy which can sample
objects in proportion to their reward
and I will motivate and introduce two
new objectives called detail balance and
trajectory balance which are the ones
that we most often often use in practice
in applications of jonet and I'll
conclude with some discussion of uh how
to train how to train your
gonet now um just to review and to set
up um set up background unfortunately my
figure is not
animated but this is the kind of figure
that we just saw in emanu talk we have a
direct directed aycc graph which
specifies the structure of generative
process we have an initial State here
labeled S zero and and we can follow the
edges in the picture from left to right
until we reach a terminal state which is
marked with a
square we think of we think of the
terminal objects as representing
completed terminal States as
representing completed objects like the
molecules or smiley faces that we're
trying to
generate and we learned in the last talk
that that when we assign a number to
every Edge a
flow we can extract from this flow a
policy which is just as in RL a way
of getting a distribution over
subsequent States when we're sitting at
a particular
State the way we turn a flow into a
policy is by taking the flows to all of
the children of the state we're at and
dividing by the sum in other words
normalizing to get a probability distrib
so for instance we may be at s0 so we
look at a flow to S1 and to S2 and we
our policy goes to S1 or to S2 in
proportion with probability proportional
to the flow to S1 and to S2 and so on
until reaching a terminal
State what we're trying to achieve
through any G flet training procedure is
to make the marginal likelihood that the
policy will terminate in a
given completed object proportional to
its
reward and the main result that we that
we covered that Emanuel covered in the
last talk is that when we enforce a
local condition that at every state the
flow in equals the flow out the policy
that's obtained from this flow happens
to sample proportionally to the
reward this is the first main theorem of
jets that if flow matching is satisfied
at every
State inside the state space then the
corresponding policy samples in
proportion to the
reward so nothing new so
far but there are some problems with
this objective which uh Emanuel already
alluded to so let's uh go through those
um the first one is that it's a local
objective that is the objective at a
particular State depends only on the
flows into out of that state not other
ones in other parts of the state space
now when we perform an update at one
state we still might affect the edge
flows somewhere far away and that's due
to the neural net parameterization of
flows so the flow function is given to
us by a neural network and so we change
the parameters when we update the edge
flow in one part of a graph so it might
affect the edge flow in another part of
the graph this is important for
generalization on the other hand this
locality still has a
limitation and this limitation is
something that happens in other
reinforcement settings as well and it's
the problem of slope granted
assignment I can illustrate it with this
figure so imagine that so our graph is
going top down here so imagine that we
sampled our policy and we saw a very
high reward State this x at the
bottom and the flows on the edges along
this trajectory were very small so what
will happen which Edge flows will get
updated when I got this very high reward
State
well the flow matching might be very
close to satisfied at all of the all of
the states in the beginning of the
trajectory where flows are small so the
only place where there there's a
discrepancy would be at the very end
where the inflow is small but we got a
high reward so I should increase the
edge flow there so the only update
happens near the end so now this um this
Edge there
no gets a higher get gets a higher float
through a grade end update so now what
has to happen to propagate this
information about a high reward state
closer to the beginning of the graph
well we have to see this previous
state and so until I see that state
again I won't get any update so imagine
I saw this state again now the outflow
is high now but inflow is still small
so now that one has to be updated and
the signal is propagated one step closer
to the initial State and so on and if
trajectories are long and the likelihood
of reaching these states is small it can
take a very long time to get an update
to flows or policies near the beginning
of the trajectory when we H have um a an
interesting State at the end this is the
problem of slow credit assignment and
it's a major limitation of gfets with
local training
objectives now another problem with flow
measuring which Emanuel also mentioned
is the possibly High computation
cost we we usually when we train models
with matching we have a model which
takes in a state and outputs
simultaneously The Edge flows to all of
the subsequent uh all of the children of
that state in the single neural network
usually actually the model is outputting
the logs of those States but that's not
what what's important here um so flow
matching is trying to enforce that
inflow equals outflow and Computing the
outflow is easy in this green rectangle
we just have to evaluate our neural net
and sum all of the edge flows that it
outputs the flows to all the children
but Computing the inflow is not so easy
because we would have to evaluate our
model at all the parents of the state of
Interest so if there are n parents then
to compute the flow matching loss we
need n plus one neural net evaluations
to compute the loss and for problems
with many parents for any given State
this can be
prohibitive so that that's a problem we
want to avoid
that and this um the this this
observation is what motivated the
introduction of the first loss that's
not flow matching called deta
balance so I'll will introduce this one
next
so the idea of detailed balance is that
instead of working with Edge flows we'll
introduce a different
parameterization so we will directly
learn the policy the the policy which is
a distribution over children of every
state in the graph it's just like in
refor learning it's output by a model
which takes the state as input and gives
us the Logics of all of the possible
actions all of the possible
children and in addition to the policy
we need some auxiliary
objects so I'll explain them in reverse
order so the we need a special object
called a backward policy and I'll talk a
little more about what it actually means
in a while but you should think of it as
a policy which can start at a terminal
State and Sample backward until getting
to an initial state so it's a
distribution or a model that gives a
distribution over the parents of any
state in the
graph and this looks a little funny
because why would we ever want to start
at a terminal State and Sample backwards
get a trajectory that leads there but
this can actually be useful as I'll talk
about near the end and in addition to
those we learn a single single estimator
neural net that gives us one number
scaler for every state called the state
flow and you should think of this as so
when flow matching is satisfied then
flow in equals flow out and they're both
equal to something called the state flow
it's the amount flowing amount of water
flowing through the
state now how is um how is this
parameterization related to the one used
in flow matching so if we look
at if we look at the forward policy and
how is defined in terms of the flow so
this bottom left here um the likelihood
of passing to a child V from a state s
is proportional to the flow from s to V
so it's the flow on the edge as to V
divided by the sum of all the flows
coming
out um and similarly the backward policy
can be defined in terms of a flow so
instead of normalizing over all of the
children we normalize all the over all
the parents so to decide which parent to
transition to the backward policy takes
the flow to all the parents and
normalizes to get a distribution suing
to
one um so if we look at these two
equations um we see that there two
different ways to express the state flow
just via
algebra the state flow is on the one
hand the outflow of the parent times the
forward policy the likelihood so the
outflow at s times the likelihood of
transitioning from s to S Prime and on
the other hand it's the inflow at S
Prime Times the backward likelihood so
the the backward policy is probability
of transitioning from S Prime to
S
so the the key key part here is the
equality of these two ways of writing
the edge
flow we can visualize it also on the
picture on the right where these two
quantities inflow at inflow at S Prime
Times backward policy or outflow at
stimes forward policy are both supposed
to be equal to the flow on the Edge from
s to S
Prime so now um some magic happens and
we turn this equality into a training
objective so remember that we're
learning f and the backward policy PB
and the forward policy PF so we take
this equality and make it a constraint
that we try to
enforce so the detail balance objective
for an edge from s to S Prime is trying
to make these two quantities equal so
this is just like the flow matching
constraint INF flow equals outflow is
turned into objective log of inflow
divided by outflow squ we do the same
thing
here and just like um just like in flow
matching this
um we can stabilize this by adding small
smoothing constants to numerator and
denominator and um let's take a closer
look at this
lesson so first of
all this is written as a log of some
products and quotients but because we're
outputting flows in log domain and
because we're outputting policies
through their log
logits we can do some algebra and turn
this into just a sum of logs squared so
it's just a quadratic Closs in terms of
the logits and the stage
list and um let's also think about what
happens at the terminal States at the
terminal States we know that the inflow
is supposed to equal the reward and with
the detail balance loss um because the
inflow is and the outflow are the same
thing as the state flow we're learning
we can just force that the state flow
equals the reward at Terminal States so
this is like a boundary condition that
reinforce in addition to this detail
balance objective which has to be
satisfied on every Edge inside the
graph and um from the algebra on the
previous slide we can see that if the
detail balance
constraint holds on every
Edge then the edge flow that we recover
from mid by writing the edge flow as
state flow times
policy satisfies flow matching so by the
first main theorem about G flow Nets the
policy is sampling proportionally to the
reward
now this parameterization involves no
Edge flows it involves two policies and
a state
flow um we can reduce the number of
objects involved by fixing the backward
policy to some simple distribution of
our choice I just want to note this here
and I'll come back to this a little
later okay so we have detailed balance
and it solves the problem of summing
over a large number of parents because
it depends only on a single edge but
it's still local and so it still has the
credit assignment problem that I
discussed a few slides ago so it would
be nice if we instead had a trajectory
level objective that is one that sees a
reward from a terminal State and
immediately sends a gradient update to
all of the edges seen along the
trajectory and
um when um and we struggled with that
for a long time to find such an
objective we first came up with it in
the case of a tree-shaped graph where
states only have one parent and then
eventually we had this realization that
um we can get a simple trajectory level
objective which I'll derive for you
now so now comes now comes the the maist
slide of the presentation so I promise
it's only downhill from there or uphill
depending on how you see
it so let's look at a
trajectory so it starts at the initial
State as zero and it takes M steps ends
at a state SN which I also call x x is
usually a terminal State and let's write
the detail balance constraint on each
Edge and I write in this way in the same
form that it appears in the loss
so f * PF equals f * PB so I write that
the quotient equals one for all of those
Transitions and SN is a terminal state
so the flow at the terminal State equals
the reward R of all of those equal one
now let's take all of these constraints
and let's multiply them together so
they're all equal to one so their
product equals
one um so I've done nothing here just
multiplied all the equalities in the
first line now a lot of cancellation is
going to happen because the flow in the
denominator of one term cancels with the
flow in the numerator of the next term
so all the flows cancel except the very
first F of s z and the very last R ofx
and we're left with
this so I've just done some
rearrangement of
terms so let's look at this so in the
numerator we have the flow at s0 and
then the product of all of the policies
transition probabilities along the
trajectory from s0 all the way to
SN and the in the denominator we have
the reward and then the product of
backward transition probabilities as we
uh start from X and then we go backward
along this
trajectory and no other state flows
survived now that's pretty
nice so we have this uh so-called the
trajectory balance constraint which says
that this numerator and this denominator
are equal now I can also write it in
this condensed form so flow it as zero
times a forward likelihood of that whole
trajectory PF of to just means the
product of those transition
probabilities in the numerator equals
the reward times the product of all the
backward transitions in the
denominator now I write PB of to given X
because the backward probability of a
trajectory only makes sense if I know
where to start that backward trajectory
at a terminal at a given terminal
statex so when we have some constraint
and shets we want to turn into a
loss let's do that we for a trajectory
we just enforce with the same kind of
squared log ratio trick we enforce that
these two quantities are equal so the
log of um
initial State flow times forward policy
forward likelihood of the trajectory
divided by reward times backward
likelihood of the trajectory squared
we're supposed to minimize
that so this objective is trajectory
level so we it depends on all of the
Transitions and their forward and
backward
probabilities so when we see a
trajectory and we get a reward we
immediately get an update to all of this
all of the transitions that we had in
the trajectory so it's a global
effctive now there's a there's a theorem
and it's not exactly obvious that why
holds that if we make this objective
hold so if we make f * pfals R * PB for
every trajectory this is sufficient for
the foreign policy to sample
proportionally to the reward so the
derivation I showed shows it's necessary
because from detailed balance through
this cancellation we get trajectory
balance but the other way requires
requires some requires doing some
math so practically what do we do we
sample a trajectory from from our policy
or from some more exploratory version
you'll hear about that in the next talk
and we perform gradient updates
on this uh TB TB image
act let's take a closer look at what
properties it has now I've already said
this is a global objective so it leads
to faster credit assignment due to um
yielding a gradient update to every
state along a trajectory when a reward
is received in addition it doesn't
require learning the state flow for
every
state for for every state only for the
initial State f ofs z everything else
canel in our
derivation and just like like Emanual
mentioned before the F ofs zero that
which we do have to learn at convergence
ends up being equal to the total reward
so the sum of all rewards of terminal
States we use the letter Z to denote
that
often now here's a point which um which
is very important in understanding
gonets as a variational inference
algorithm um the TB loss is actually
doing
something something with a a deeper
meaning so it's equating we trying to
make equal two distributions Not Over
States but over
trajectories one of them is the
distribution of trajectories that you
sample by starting at the initial State
and then sampling the forward
policy the other one is the one that you
sample by taking a terminal State
sampled from the true reward
distribution now we can usually do that
we want to learn and then following the
backward policy from that state back to
the initial state as
zero um the trajectory balance objective
is trying to make those two
distributions over trajectories equal by
making the ratio of likelihoods equal to
one so one consideration that falls out
of that is that we can actually fix the
backward policy so given a terminal
State we can just decide once and for
all from the beginning without having it
learned what what is the posterior
distribution over trajectories that will
get us to that
state we we can for example make the
backward policy uniform so that's a
common choice because it often
simplifies it reduces the number of
models we have to learn
um when when when I'm just starting to
prototype a Chinet I often just start
with the trajectory balance with the
uniform background policy because it's
very
simple um if we fix the backward policy
at every state to be uniform over the
parents then the only things we have to
learn are the initial initial State flow
and the forward policy very simple right
so it's just like in reinforcement
learning where we just learn a policy or
maybe sometimes a value function except
we just have to learn one extra thing
which is the initial State
flow and a practical consideration is
that this initial State flow we often
learn in the log domain and it often
helps to set a Higher Learning rate on
that because it can be trained stably
even with a high um even with a large
updates
so just some results um as as as we saw
trajectory balance allows you to find
more modes and converge faster generally
than other training
objectives on the bid sequence task
here's a molecule domain where we first
implemented and tested trajectory
balance so we get more stable training
more um modes discovered and so higher
diversity and higher reward of the
typically generated
objects
now I want to conclude with some um
practical considerations about how to
choose an
objective so you're you want to train a
JL net for your problem you decided what
objects you want to generate you
designed the state and action space so
you decided the generative process that
you're going to use so what objective
should you use well so I think that
trajectory balance is a good objective
to try by default because um it's fairly
simple to implement and it yields a fast
graded assignment on the other hand it
has some limitations which are that it
can have a high gradient variance and
high memory cost especially if the
trajectories are very long or there's a
very high range of rewards that you
encounter
so sometimes you might want to try
something based on Flow matching or
detail balance
instead now in general detail balance
does not work as well
in in in settings that we often
encounter um unless some special
constraints are satisfied um there's um
there's a trick called the
forward-looking flow parameterization in
which if you can compute some kind of
proxy reward at not complete States at
incomplete States intermediate States
then you can parameterize the log flow
function not directly through a neural
network but as an additive correction to
this proxy log reward
and if there's interest I can give a few
examples of that in the
questions there are similar tricks Poss
possible if from every state is allowed
to terminate which is the case in some
generative
problems and
um there we can also
learn the flow function as a correction
to the reward of that object if we chose
to terminate
there and there's no another objective
called sub trajectory balance which I
won't go into but which is a kind of
interpolation between detail balance and
trajectory balance so trajectory balance
learns from an entire trajectory by
multiplying together the detail balance
constraints and then canceling all the
state flows detail balance learns from a
single edge so sub trajectory balance U
does this but takes a partial trajectory
starting not necessarily at s z ending
not necessarily at a terminal State and
performs this cancellation so that only
the state flow at the start of the sub
trajectory and at the end are remaining
and um combining the detailed
balance Edge level trajectory balance um
whole trajectory level and sub
trajectory balance for partial pieces in
the appropriate way can give us the best
of both worlds in terms of stable
training with the low gradient variance
coming from detailed balance and a fast
credit assignment that comes from
trajectory level objectives
so I'll will finish with that and uh
here are the main references for the
losses and ideas I've
discussed and you can check out um any
of those if you're interested thank
you we're a little behind schedule but
we have five minutes for
questions
hi yeah thank you for the nice
presentation I I have a question about
the how to choose like how to get
samples so I remember that like the in
the training process uh ml mentioned
that the policy could be off policy but
in practice like which policy we should
choose um that that's a good question so
so we know that for the forward policy
to sample proportionally to the reward
trajectory balance or detailed balance
or flow matching has to be satisfied at
every state or at every Edge or at every
trajectory so we are actually free to
choose any training policy we like as
long as it has full
support um now what we do in practice
this is the subject of the next
presentation but just to give you a
preview um common techniques are some
modification to the on policy training
like introducing random actions or
tempering as well as using information
about known ter states such as those
obtained through replay buffer so if we
have interesting terminal States we can
train on backward trajectory sample from
them but you'll hear more in the next
talk thank you uh can I ask another
question like how can we choose the
length of sub trajectory in practice as
well um for sub trajectory balance yeah
um well that's an interesting question I
don't know the best answer but what we
did in the paper on sub trajectory
balance is we took all of the subtr
and we weighted them in proportion to
some constant Lambda to the power of the
length which is inspired by a technique
called TD Lambda in reinforcement
learning okay thank
you considering the trajectory balance
objective you said that sometimes common
practice is to set the backwards policy
to a uniform I have a hard time
understanding how this wouldn't like
just enforce the forward policy to also
be uniform like does how does this
actually let us still sample
proportional to the
reward well first the theoretical side
of that answer is that um for any
backward policy you choose there's a
unique forward policy such that together
they optimize the trajectory balance
objective um now how do we understand
that
so we think of TB as equating to
distributions over trajectories so let's
start with the this backward distrib
distribution we can sample it by taking
a terminal state from the reward
distribution which imagine Oracle can
sample for you and then sampling uniform
back
policy so that distribution over
trajectories can also be sampled
forward and if those two distributions
are equal then their marginal
distributions over the terminal state
are also the same and for the backward
one by construction it's the reward
distribution so for the forward one it
has to be the same oh I see thank you
and um yeah I suggest you can read the
paper on dronets and variational
inference for a discussion of
this thanks k for the talk uh I guess my
question is what if you cannot uh
enumerate parents like if it's just too
difficult because even for the backwards
policy I guess you have to know how many
you
have uh yes that's so the question the
question as I understand it is even if
you're fixing the backward policy to
uniform so one over number of parents
you still need to know how many parents
there
are and
um
now if you have never gotten your hands
dirty with gonets it might not make
sense why that can even be a problem but
in fact it can be for example in
molecule generation when there are many
ways to remove a component from a
molecule you may get possible parents
which are equal due to isomorphism so
there are different um different
construction orders for the same
molecule uh and it's a difficult graph
isomorphism check to determine if two
ways of expressing the same molecule are
actually the same
so well there's nothing you can do about
that you have to do an isomorphism check
on the parents I don't have a better
answer okay you can do faster morphism
checks if you learn um if you have a
learned hasher embedding for the parents
which allows you to quickly deter if two
um two molecules are
isomorphic but yeah that that could
arise in other settings where hatching a
graph is not is not necessarily the
answer uh it could be also in domain
uncertainty of but anyway so I guess the
answer is you go you have to you have to
find a way to inate the
parents
okay in that case
um we will have our next talk so let's
let's take a break until
11:05
e
get your
bio
I just share screen share
screen okay let's
resume doesn't work doesn't
okay right um before before we continue
to the next talk I have an important
announcement so after this talk we're
going to have a practical session and
for this you'll need to if you want to
run some code on your own device you
need to set up you need to download some
code with u environment and some
prerequisites and I just want to let you
know that those the links to those are
now posted on the jet.org
schedu P the page with the schedule of
the workshop so you can download that
and prepare for the Practical
session right that was the important
announcement and now um let me introduce
our next speaker Jared rapor Brooks who
is a PhD student at University deal and
Milan and co-founder of the molecular
design startup dream fold his as a PhD
student supervised by yosua Benjo and
sarth chander his research interests
span generative modeling and
probabilistic inference with
applications to protein binder
design and he will tell us about pra
practical side the Practical side of
training G
flets thanks COA um hi everybody so I'm
gonna talk about what Co said I'm gonna
talk about so let's talk about it um
okay so G Nets G Nets are an interesting
thing we've talked about there's a lot
of parallels or there's a lot of
connections between RL generative
modeling and G Nets these come in forms
like coia mentioned earlier there's deep
connections between variational
inference and gone Nets and in
particular the way we train gance is
very similar to reinforcement
learning in reinforcement learning right
we have an mdp we take steps
sequentially and we get rewards over
time in gfets we do about the same thing
we have some mdp something which is
saying at least in the SCP space we have
an MP something that's saying from this
state I can take these actions and I'm
going to transition to these other
places and specifically at the end of an
episode at the end of uh trajectory we
get some
reward um so gener models also not
really like this we train them very
differently but they kind of in a way do
a similar thing um where you have data
set instead of having uh not a data set
um but you train them to match uh a
target distribution and specifically in
the variational inference case you can
recover some very similar things to what
we do with uh G
FL so as uh Emanuel and colia already
mentioned there's really a core training
Loop of what we do for G Nets so it's
pretty simple it's it's it's just like
RL right so the first thing we do we
have some policy and we say Okay policy
let's let's generate some experiences so
we get this batch of experiences somehow
and then next we're going to get some
rewards a gonet is all about the
terminal rewards right what gonets do is
they sample objects as Emanuel was
talking about um proportional to the
reward of those objects and so these
objects we say are basically the um the
states we arrive at at the end of a
trajectory um so we generate our batch
of experiences from our forward policy
and we get some rewards for the objects
that these trajectories generated and
then we compute the loss on these
trajectories and so here make a quick
note this uh this notation is a little
bit different I'm saying that we're
sampling a trajectory from the forward
policy which is the same ways of writing
the same thing we had before um if we
recall that a policy is a maravian
policy then the likelihood of sampling
of AA a trajectory is just the product
of all the transitions in the
trajectory
so this is the core training Loop
cool basically the first and third part
are very interchangeable so Kia was
already talking about what do we do for
step number three there's a bunch of
different objective functions all of
these try to do the same thing in
principle they have we have a set of
constraints for Gil Nets and we want to
try to say that everywhere in space at
all different times these constraints
are satisfying
because if we do this then we get what
we want we get a sampler um that samples
objects proportional to the reward so
that's one side of things the other side
of things is how do we actually choose
how do we get the data that we're going
to use to train our G
Nets and so what we're going to focus on
in this talk is specifically how do we
get these this data how do we get the
things that we're going to train our
gonet on
so how do we do this there's two main
levers the first lever um as people have
talked about is how do we generate this
data right so just like an RL um we have
a policy we simulate the policy um to
get back
experiences we can choose how we want to
generate these experiences we can change
our policy we can do different things to
make it more exploratory or maybe make
it focus on specific modes more um and
so we have ultimate Freedom really to
choose how we want to do this this goes
back to one of the core important things
of gilet which is that because of the
way the objectives work and the way the
math works out you can train them off
policy you can get samples you can get
data from wherever you want if you train
if you train everywhere you will get a
sampler that does what you want of
course we don't sample everywhere but
the point is you don't have to sample as
in VI as in variational inference what
you typically or what you might have to
do is you generate things according to
the thing you've already learned and now
if you want to go away from this you
have to import an sample and this is sad
we don't want to do this it's unstable
it's not as fun um but because of the
way G objectives work you don't have to
do this you can sample whereever you
want just as long as you try to satisfy
defil balance or flow matching or
trajectory balance or whatever other
balance you're happy so this is one
lever how do we choose what uh how do we
design a policy how do we get a policy
that's going to help us discover modes
which is important right like this
especially as you scale the problems As
you move the problems from you know the
toy like great world tasks to really big
real world tasks right like the thing
that I'm interested is protein design
and for some of the proteins that you
might want to generate like they're say
200 length long and there's 20 amino
acids so how big is that that's a search
space of 20 to the 200th this is hard to
explore it's just hard and also there's
other hard things right I mean you could
imagine having um a very non smooth
reward functions which is something that
we want to do sometimes right sometimes
we want what do we really want like if
we're doing a search problem we want to
generate the best things the the best
molecules or the best proteins or best
Crystal structures um and we want to
generate a diverse set of these but to
get the best ones you have to sample G
Nets are going to sample proportional
reward so you might have to make your
reward function rather non-s smooth um
and more peaky to try to um to try to
sample more often the things that are
really good but the more peaky your
distribution is the more likely you
might get you might be to get stuck in
modes and get mode collapse and be sad
so
um we should figure out a good way to do
this and we've done a bunch of things um
the second thing is that now once we
have the data that we've generated how
do we choose even for the data we've
generated which things we actually want
to train on so this is stuff like emanu
was mentioning earlier replay buffers
how do we choose of the data that we
have which things we want to use and
depending on the way we do this you can
see rather significant differences in
how fast you train um but as Emanuel
said with caveats all right so designing
an exploratory policy so let's say we
have a Target policy this is RPF that
we've talked about so far today and this
thing is like your normal G Net policy
right it's trying to um it's going to
try to satisfy detailed balance or
trajectory balance and it's going to try
to sample proportional to the reward at
the end of the day
so we can also have a behavior policy
just like an RL um whose job is just to
generate samples that are good for PF to
learn on what do we want we want
something that learns the distribution
we want to be able to sample from R so
all we care about is can we get a
behavior policy which is going to make
learning to sample R as easy it as it
can be for the Target policy
um there's a bunch of considerations
here right but one main thing is we want
to try to have the behavior policy be we
call full support over the uh object
distribution so you can imagine if you
do not have full support so what do I
mean like let's say we have this grid
here right and we have a a behavior
policy which ends up kind of saturating
in some way and it only samples the top
left
corner if you show this to a g- phone
it'll be perfectly happy it doesn't care
like it will see I can go to these four
states okay cool I'll learn my Zed and
the trajectory balance to be the
partition function for those four states
I can it'll um learn PF and PB according
to that partition function and the loss
can go to zero everywhere and the target
policy will never sample anything um
besides those poor states so we don't
want this so we want to make sure we
sample everywhere um and as long as
we're we have some likelihood that we're
going to sample everywhere at least in
theory eventually we should converge to
um a true correct G Net policy um of
course this doesn't necessarily happen
in practice but in theory it is true
okay exploration for
GFS okay obvious first try what should
we do let's just take the the current
Target policy but this is dumb don't do
this I mean it could be okay but like in
general it's not great so like I was
saying same thing you could imagine you
have
um like your current Target policy isn't
constrained to to sample from everything
and so we see this happening here we
have this true distribution where it's
very peaky these Corners there's three
corners that have um some reward and the
gal Net's going stop start from the top
left corner and it's perfectly fine for
this gelet to just go and find one
mode and you can pretty easily see I
mean you you can train this yourself and
you'll pretty easily see that the loss
goes to zero but what happens is it just
learns to generate maybe one of the
modes and even within the mode it's not
even capturing all the other uh states
that are right next to it it's perfectly
fine to just saturate and mode collapse
and this is kind of expected there's uh
there's an interesting little proof in
um the G Net and variational inference
paper which shows that if you learn uh
specifically with trajectory B balance
um on policy the gradient you get is the
same as the gradient of the reverse KL
and we know from generative modeling
this is not a good thing to do the
reverse K has problems with Mo collapse
and you see exactly the same behavior if
you do on policy learning um and G Net
as you would in RL as well
um so a second try we can do some rather
simple things that interestingly seem to
work in many cases
um so just like in RL we can mix in
uniform noise with the current policy
that we're
learning so the most obvious example of
this is to take an Epsilon random policy
just like Epsilon greedy and RL and so
we say that uh with likelihood one minus
Epsilon we're going to sample an action
from the target policy um and with
probability Epsilon we'll just take a
random
action the other version of this is
really the the way that we use GES in
practice is that we uh we as many other
things learn the log GS and this gives
us boltzman distribution and so as in
other boltzman distributions you can
learn a temperature which controls how
peaky or how flat this uh this
distribution becomes and so we can use
this temperature parameter um whereas if
you increase the temperature um if you
yeah if you increase the
temperature the policy becomes more flat
and if you bring that temperature to
zero it becomes very peaky around the
thing that it thinks is best and so one
approach is to just take a
policy and take the uh sorry take the
logs that we learned for the Target
policy and temper the distribution with
some
like value of temperature greater than
one so basically have a slightly more
flat distribution um than the target
policy um and these actually kind of
work rather like surprisingly
well most G Net papers use this to to
date I mean we've run experiments where
at least in small scales for example in
small scale settings these work really
really well like you it's hard to beat
this like in smaller scale settings um
even as you scale like there's an
interesting experiment we did at some
point where we had um it was an RNA
generation task and you have about 20
million States so not near as big as you
know 20 to the 200 um but 20 million
States and with this exploration the
gonet finds every mode that exists very
quickly
um but this has failure cases as you
might expect specifically as the reward
becomes more sparse
um so like I was saying if the reward
basically becomes less smooth um or if
the search bace is very very very large
these things can start to fail and so
this is um learning with a tempered
policy on the same problem as before um
and just as with an on policy um
distribution or on policy exploration
policy it mode collapses and goes to one
thing
um so how do we avoid this we don't like
this this is sad there's some ways to do
this right I mean you could imagine in
this case right like you could you could
even game it with these right you could
have a fully random policy like this
would be fine this would work you could
have a fully random policy or you could
bring the temperature very very high um
which people also do this is a typical
thing that people do in mcmc for example
for example with replica exchange where
you have many different uh mcmc chains
all at different different temperatures
and the uh higher temperature ones
higher temperature mcmc chains are more
likely to sample everywhere in the space
and you can kind of mix these things and
there is a uh there's a recent gelet
paper that is doing something similar
with temperature uh with
uh choosing the temperature um of the
tempered
policy um but there's other approaches
that people typically use in RL and
we'll cover briefly two of these
approaches so first
something that's very useful in RL is to
try to use intrinsic rewards to
encourage
exploration um so a paper in iar 2023 uh
tried to do this with gonets and so
basically we use uh a pseudo count to
augment the reward of a terminal State
and so basically we change the reward
such that um for places we have not
visited
um the G is is incentivized to visit
them more and as it visits more and more
the reward goes down and the gonet is
less likely to sample this so this paper
in particular uses R&D um which is a way
to do pseudo accounts in RL um and works
rather well specifically when we have a
very sparse reward so here is uh this
is um two results on the left they take
a very very sparse grid and in this case
the
um this sort
of intrinsic reward approach works very
well um very similarly for molecules
that use a sparse version of a molecule
task this also works very well um
there's other things you can do right
another RL exploration Paradigm is to
use uncertainty and there's much work on
this direction um and so
this also works in some cases if the U
if the search Bas is very large or if it
is if it is sparse as well um and so
what you do here is very much like
bootstrap dqn an RL you keep a a
Ensemble of policies at each uh step you
choose uh a member of The Ensemble and
generate a track trajectory according to
this member of The
Ensemble um you can encourage diversity
in multiple uh multiple ways in The
Ensemble with bootstrapping or prior
networks but this is like these are two
versions of these things this is a
general recipe right exploration for G
Nets isn't that much different than an
RL there's many ways to use uncertainty
to um give better ways to explore in RL
there's many ways to use uh intrinsic
rewards there's many ways to do
exploration besides these things in RL
these are all things that probably will
work probably will be very useful they
haven't been tried um and so if people
are interested in this they should try
these are these are good things to try
um so yeah if the exploration problem is
a bit harder if the distribution is
maybe not so um easy to generalize to
for example Thompson sampling works
well um there's other things we can do
say we have a data set say we know some
really good samples we can take a
um we can take one of these really good
examples X and we can simulate a or we
can sample a trajectory from our
backwards policy and train on that
trajectory and this has been very useful
in a bunch of different papers from um
back in 2022 on um energy based modeling
with gfns doing em with gfns also doing
things for um making exploration better
with mcmc this also works there where
for example you take something that is
close to a mode you do a small chain on
it to get a really even better um sample
and then you train on the backwards
trajectory that you get from those very
good um samples and like I said you can
also play um with tempering the reward
distribution uh as in um as in replica
exchange for example the uh temperature
conditional
paper so what thing you should you do
it's uh the first rule is just don't do
on policy like this is just don't do
this but besides this it's not so clear
uh you just start basically I think the
easiest thing to do is just start out
with Epsilon noisy or tempering this
works for a lot of settings like it
really works for a lot of settings or
things that are getting harder you might
need to start being a bit more smart
maybe try something like um jfn or
Thompson sampling or if you're feeling
brave try your own uh new like
uncertainty method or entrance reward or
take something off the shelf from RL it
might work um if you do have a data set
you should use it mixing and training
trajectory sampled from backwards policy
is quite powerful and is very useful if
you have access to samples which in some
cases we
do all right so that is exploration now
what is the um what is the next thing is
we have data we've generated a bunch of
data from our exploratory policy how do
we choose what data we're actually going
to train on so let's say we' generated a
banch of trajectories from our Behavior
policy how do we choose which of these
trajectories to train on right so
there's been a bit of research into this
and right now there's basically three
options the first is just don't use a
buffer just take the batch of
trajectories train on it second that
people do commonly is take a standard
like uniform first and first out buffer
as an RL and the third thing that people
have done um
is is take again a first and first out
buffer and try to prioritize based on
reward people have also tried a bit uh
prioritizing based on um the loss but I
think the results on this areis less
welled at this point um so reward
prioritized buffers this is uh from a
paper with Emanuel and nille uh and also
in a paper with Andre naika uh from
2022 um and so here the ideas we have a
a batch or we have a bunch of
trajectories and States uh in a buffer
and we can try to prioritize those
states which have higher like or higher
higher reward um and train on these more
than other things and so the specific
scheme that most uh of these reward
prioritized buffers have done is
basically take the top Alpha quantile of
Rewards or objects with rewards in the
buff ER and choose beta percent of your
training batch from this and one minus
beta percent from the rest of your
buffer there's other ways you can do
this you can just sample um proportional
to the reward and the buffer these
things also can work but this can be
pretty useful um
specifically it's been found in for
example Manual's paper that basically if
you do this um you will converge to uh a
good value perhaps faster and in some of
nil's work that you can discover more
modes but it does come with caveats
right um You have to be careful with how
you're doing this if you do this naively
if you make it too in a sense greedy
choose too much too big of a beta or
make the top percent too small say
you're only training on the top 05% you
can run into a very myopic policy you
can end up with Mo collapse again um and
so there are things you can do you can
try TR to um you could try to add in
some measure of diversity in how you're
doing this um maybe in your insertion
strategy or in your sampling strategy
from the buffer or you can just play
with the hyperparameters but you have to
be careful I mean imagine right like if
you're just choosing the best things
you're just gonna start keep choosing
the best things and you might Mo
collapse so this can be very useful for
training
just make sure you're not doing the
wrong thing just make sure
the things you're doing or the results
you're getting are making some
sense okay so wrapping
up for exploration what should we do
steer away from doing on policy learning
start with just simple exploration
things just like an RL do Epsilon noisy
and tempered things if this doesn't work
try out more RL like um exploration
methods like tail Nets which try to do
intrinsic rewards Thompson sampling
which tries do uncertainty or genuinely
you could try many different rnl things
that people have done for uncertainty
and it may work out pretty well um for
replays uniform buffers don't seem to
have help all that much there's been
some results um on this I think just in
general people have not seen a huge
difference between just using a uniform
buffer
um just using a uniform buffer versus
just training on the batch of
trajectories you've generated perhaps if
you try to add in something around
diversity you might get some better
um making sure you're not like
forgetting modes um but just vanilla
uniform 5 buffers don't seem to help
much but re prioritized buffers do seem
to help so try them just make sure
you're not doing something that's making
your policy
die so yeah happy training couple quick
helpful things just small things that
can make a big difference um that are
not related to exploration or replay
buffers so stabilizing learning this can
be a big deal especially as your rewards
become very big so for example if we
want to do search we want to make some
of our rewards very big especially if a
very big search space you have to do it
otherwise you just won't sample your
even if your gonet converges to the
right thing it won't sample what you
want um so you in some cases just need
to make your reward very very non-s
smooth for search to work and so in
these cases you can start running into
issues with stability um gradient
clipping is critical on some problems
you might have to play around with Hyper
parameters um using delayed Network um
to can help training so using EMA on uh
exponential moving average on model
weights can be useful there's recent
work on target networks to help
stabilize things um
and so on another thing that I forgot to
put on here and I'm just remembering um
normalizing the reward making sure
trying to get your reward into As Nice
of a scale that you can under the
constraints that you have can be quite
important um and another trick we've
found that can sometimes help a lot um
when specifically you have a very re uh
low reward
um very low reward temperature uh T So
this means basically your reward is
going to be very spiky because you're
dividing reward by this temperature
right so maybe it's one e neg5 or
something and so it means your reward
gets very spiky rescaling the loss by um
the temperature to some some exponent
maybe one can be critical for not making
everything blow up um so yeah that's it
if people have questions I am happy to
answer them
I have a question about the expiration
strategy you talked about you briefly
mentioned count count based expiration
and random nro distillation usually
these techniques assign a reward at the
current state but for Gil we only assign
rewards at the terminal state so my
question is when you if you have a
trajectory do you estimate that
exploration reward along to along along
the trajectory or just the terminal
state or at every state then for
propagated you can uh actually in the
gaet paper one of the contributions is
to be able to use intermediate rewards
and help this for um sampling um you can
do this it might help your problem I
think it's problem dependent if it helps
versus even just using the reward or
account based exploration on the
terminal States but you can do this if
you're interested check out the gfm
paper thank you
I was just wondering what which methods
would you prioritize in a situation
where you know in advance that all the
trajectories you have available for
training start
wrong something exploratory I suppose
something exploratory I mean you could
start out with something with a very
large value of a very exploratory
Epsilon noisy or tempered policy you can
I mean all these exploration things have
hyper parameters that control how
exploratory they are like I would start
with higher and you can always anal your
exploration parameters down as you go
like so start high be be be exploratory
and
then hi hi like uh when I think in this
slide in this session like you pre
assume that the world functions are kind
of know right but let's say like reward
functions are unknown and we need to
learn from data in that case like should
we add more bonus term like coming from
uncertainty of like unknown reward
functions that's an interesting question
I'm not sure I have a good answer
um so you mean like inverse problem
settings or you thinking in like energy
based modeling settings where you're
trying to learn an energy uh I'm just
considering a kind of setting when the
our reward is unknown and we need to
learn from the
data I think it's not at least to me
it's not clear I would say try things
try a bunch of different values maybe
coia seems like you might have an
idea
yeah if I may make a little comment on
that there have I've seen a few settings
where you learn the reward either
because the reward is given by
likelihood under a generative model or
as an energy based model where your
estimate of the reward function starts
out really smooth and when the reward
function starts really smooth it's
easier to learn the policy to match it
and um as the reward function evolves
and becomes spikier it becomes harder to
explore and in this setting actually
exploration is a lot less important
because it's easier without exploration
to match a very smooth smooth reward
function and as as the reward function
becomes peier you gradually settle into
the mode
but I suppose it always depends on the
specific problem at
hand great can I ask another question
like uh I remember that the so like
there is a kind of analogy for like Q
learning and also like flow matching
objective right and are there any like
the similar Concepts to like which are
analogous to like a policy gradients
stuff
uh I think there is actually a very
recent work somebody else might be more
familiar but I think there was a recent
work submitted
uh to I clear maybe on policy gradient
with G Nets I think there's there's
recent work on this if you look it up it
should be around okay thank
you thank you Jared for the talk um you
mentioned earlier that there was this
connection uh between TB and you know
reverse chaos
is there a similar connection that
you're aware of for replay buffers
between a different
Divergence different averages different
Divergence like for example I don't know
like that it's not purely like a reverse
scale anymore right it would be like
some different Divergence maybe like a
mix between you know forward and
backward or some maybe yeah we thought
about this a bit I mean I think so right
I mean you well you can imagine you try
to do important sampling from your
buffer and then you could say I I have
the forward like kale but then of course
you have the important sample like um
there might be interesting ways to I
haven't maybe you thought maybe coia has
thought about it can talk about it after
there might be interesting ways to try
to think of like other divergences
besides you know something where you
have to important sample maybe you do
have to important sample I don't know
[Music]
um I think I think I have tried at some
point some important sampling um
experiments but I don't remember what
happened with them
thanks
yeah right well thank you everybody may
you
TR
right so next we have our first jlet
practical session and is Joseph here oh
yes you have to come up here so I can
introduce
you let me introduce uh Joseph vivano
who is a machine learning scientist at
Milla working on Research tooling and
applications of machine learning to
biological Discovery and he will lead
the first Hands-On session on training
gfets now there will be a few of us
walking around the room to help out for
anyone who needs
help thank
you um just let me get my screen set up
but in the mean time on the schedule at
the top of the second day you'll find
links to collabs uh for the two sessions
as well as a link to GitHub if you
prefer not to use collab for some reason
where you can download a notebook onto
your computer and run it
locally
um also there's a a bunch of Tas quote
unquote in the room there's going to be
sort of a fill-in the blank style
exercises throughout this um could all
the Tas quickly raise their hands so
that the rest can look around and and
see who they are we've got about seven
or eight okay so um what I'm going to do
is sort of talk us through this um this
notebook which is kind of designed to be
read alone actually so I won't
necessarily read every word um um but
the every time we come to sort of a
interactive portion um I'll give you
around five minutes to sort of read
through the code and and fill in the
session and you feel free to grab the
Tas who will be wandering around um
during those
moments um so the first thing that you
need to do uh would just be to execute
the top cells uh to do your Imports and
to find some helper functions um this uh
exercise is going to be building off of
uh what Emanual Benjo uh presented this
morning um where we essentially want to
generate um faces uh we want to sample
faces um more often when they're happy
than when they're sad so I'm just to uh
walk you through sort of how we would
parameterize this this is a a very
simple feature space we're going to be
sampling features one by one and a face
is going to be given as a set of
features
um so will help smiles and frowns and
then uh eyebrows of different
orientations and um if you were to um
maybe I'll pause before I keep going is
anybody not able to get something
running um feel free to just raise your
hand okay everybody's on board one oh
you don't have a laptop
okay all right
um okay so great uh what were we're
seeing here are examples of of faces so
we have you know a happy face here which
means a smile and an eyebrow one for
each eye um and then we have some
invalid configurations for example
multiple mouths overlapping that's not
good we don't want multiple eyebrows
either or we don't want faces that are
missing um eyebrows in particular
locations and so um what we need to do
if we want to sample faces um as you I I
think know already from this morning
session um
is we need to define a reward function
such that we're going to sample
proportionately to that reward function
and just to prove to ourselves that what
we're doing is working properly we're
going toh give twice the reward to a
happy face than to a sad face so that we
can observe whether our model is
actually sampling happiness more more
often than sadness and we also don't
want to sample um invalid configurations
at all um so we're going to give those
uh those configurations a reward of
zero um so here we have some functions
that are simply checking whether our um
feature list uh contains overlapping
features which is bad and then we use
that information to calculate our reward
so give zero War to overlapping uh
features within our data set I'm sorry
um our features and uh we'll give higher
rewards to happy faces than sad
faces and I as we looked at um earlier
uh this
morning you can sort of see all the
possible paths we could take uh as we're
constructing um faces um sampling these
features one by one to construct our our
final
object um and uh this is essentially the
the space that our G flet is going to be
traversing as we train it so each you
know each iteration of this is
essentially an iteration of our training
for
Loop um and so just to quickly re
reiterate the flow matching condition
which was already covered uh now uh
twice this morning um basically what we
want to do is we want for every uh state
to ensure that the flows entering that
state and exiting that state um are
equal and this is the loss function that
we're going to be using to train our our
neural network and uh as an aside here
because I know that this terminology is
overloaded network does not um in the
gflow net terminology is referring to um
the the MTP that we're traversing so we
have a function approximator that's
predicting the flows that's giving us
the probability that we're going to
sample each of the next uh actions um
and then we also have this this uh
network of flows that is implicitly
learned by the the G FL um sorry the
function
approximator
um and um you know as as we've covered
earlier of course the goal here is uh to
sample these configurations proportional
to the reward
so the first thing that we need is that
function
approximator this could be really simple
it's going to be some kind of MLP with a
hidden layer that's going to take in our
input uh state which is going to be the
presence or absence of the six features
that we've defined
already and then we're going to be
predicting uh one of six actions which
is which thing should I add next to my
my um my
state and since we want our flows to be
positive it's uh important here uh that
we're going to exponentiate the output
in in this particular
case um so here here we have our
objective function um that you've that
you've seen before uh where you have uh
essentially you
want the um the flow incoming to a state
to be equal to the reward plus the flow
outgoing to the state now why would why
would I say this the reason is because
at the terminal nodes you have only a
reward you have no outgoing flows
otherwise you have no reward you only
have outgoing flows that's why this is
this
works um okay so the first sort of uh
key exercise is U for us to be able to
figure out what the parents of a state
are in order for us to be able to
calculate um uh calculate this and for
this you're going to need to know uh
that you know we're representing um our
feature keys this is often used within
the code which is simply a list of of
strings that's used to represent the set
that that becomes your state so in this
cell uh what you should do is figure out
what the parent states are of a given
current state and um which
actions
um uh led to the current state and the
way I'm going to do this is I'll give
you a few minutes and then I'm going to
flip to the answer like a cooking show
uh so that uh nobody gets left behind if
there's something
tricky so I'll give you um all a few
minutes now
um
so I'll um draw your attention to the
screen um here what we're what we're
doing uh when we're calculating the
parent States is uh we're essentially
figuring out if there's a parent that
exists that has all parts except for the
the um a part that's currently within uh
the list uh because something must been
added in order to produce this current
state and then uh similarly for the
parent actions where simply uh you know
it's just the addition of any of the
current uh features that have produced
that state
now of course this is an exceedingly
simple example I think that one thing to
be to note here is is that in very
complicated spaces the logic here can
can actually be quite heavy um and uh it
this this might take a a reasonable
amount of thought in order to
implement
um so I'll just give you um a
moment I'll move
on
so now that we have um the ability to
calculate our our parents the other
thing that piece that we need is to be
able to calculate our loss itself so
I'll I'll give you a moment here to
implement the flow matching loss which
takes into account the incoming flows to
a state and the outgoing flows and the
reward
so just to confirm um I've put the
answer on the board for this one as well
um hopefully straight forward so we can
move on to the the the training Loop
which is a little bit more
involved
um but uh it's important to run this
next cell here which is going to define
the sort of fixed hyper parameters that
we're going to use for training all
future models the reason why is because
I wanted something that could train
quickly on a on a laptop or something
like this and we're going to be
comparing different configurations
um on models that can train in say a
minute or two so if your models are
taking longer than a few minutes then
something's wrong um and uh we can see
the difference in in the results after
we do this so if you just you can run
these hidden cells in order to produce
this text and you'll know that it's
working so now what we're going to do is
we're actually going to instantiate and
train our model uh so we're going to let
the model generate its data by following
its policy and then train on that data
um and once again the state is a list of
strings representing the keys in this uh
fun this uh feature Keys variable that
we saw before um and there's function
here that face to tensor that's going to
take that list and turn it into
something that P torch likes which is
sort of a Boolean Vector um so I'll walk
you through this this training Loop but
um hopefully it's fairly straightforward
but there are multiple lines that you
need to fill as we go through so um what
we're going to do here is uh you know in
for each episode start with an empty
State and then uh predict the flows for
given uh for that empty State and then
we're going to enter into a trajectory
of length three why because we're trying
to add three things to the face a mouth
and two eyebrows um so we're actually
making the problem a little bit easier
because if you wanted you could set up a
problem such that the model would have
to predict when to exit um but we're
we're since we already know that we only
want need three things we can we can
build this directly into the
training um then what we need oh I'm
looking at the wrong thing um pardon me
then what we need is to uh sample um an
action and compute the the new
state um so we need to calculate our
policy and then we need to sample an
action from that
policy in order to calculate our new
state recall that we're concatenating uh
strings to list in order to represent
our
states and then what we're going to do
is we're going to compute the law so we
have to enumerate the parents and then
compute the flows of each parent so in
order to do this we need to use the
function we defined before and then uh
we're going to uh get all of the parent
States and we're going to collect their
flows and index the correct uh flows to
the current
state and then at the end of the
trajectory we're either going to uh
we're going to um you know collect our
reward and Edge flow predictions which
are going to be different depending on
whether this is a terminal node or
not and we can finally calculate our
loss using the function we defined
before um the rest of this is just uh
bookkeeping so uh if I'll give you a few
minutes now to to go through this and
and fill in the blanks hopefully you
didn't get all the answers already by my
mistake and um you should be able to
train this cell
um which will produce uh training
curves um that might look something like
this and uh we can see what you got
after that after the
fact don't be afraid to ask questions um
there's lots of um if you need
help
for
that
who was a training
curve a
few okay like
10% um I think I'm going to flip to the
answer just in the interest of
time
um so what we want to do uh for for
calculating the policy is we just want
to normalize The Edge flows um by their
sum so that we get a probability
distribution and then we're going to
feed that into a categorical
distribution with the probabilities
being the policy and we're going to
sample from it to produce an action and
then that action is going to be used to
index into our future Keys list to
produce our next state which is just a
concatenation of the previous state plus
this new
string and uh here we're going to
calculate the reward if it's the end of
a
trajectory and set our outgoing Edge
flow predictions to just zero so that
that we'll sum over zero in the loss and
then we'll do something um the opposite
um otherwise if it's not the end of a
trajectory so we'll set the reward to
zero for an for intermediate State and
we'll predict the edge flows uh using
this new
state um to continue the loop
um so maybe I'll give you a moment to
fill these in if you
want
um and um after you after you do this
you'll be able to produce you know a
training curve that'll look a little bit
unstable um that will uh produce if you
check run this function check sampled
faces which is one of our hidden
functions you'll see that we're doing
okay uh we're getting like you know a
decent number of valid faces sampled and
we're getting um you know roughly the
correct ratio of happy faces although
not not correct um and uh what we can do
is we can actually visualize the flows
that are learned by our our function our
function approximator and there's a few
things that are interesting to look at
here first of all you can see that the
flows are clearly lower for um uh the
invalid configurations and also that the
the
you know the magnitude of the flows is
higher um in sort of early uh early
regions of the of the mdp which is uh is
common because we're sort of
Distributing this probability over more
and more transitions as we go deeper um
if you didn't get what happened before
that's okay because we're going to
redrew this again with most of the
functions filled out for you uh so don't
don't feel like you'll get blocked um
but uh I will pause here to see if
there's any sort of like major questions
that uh because maybe multiple people
have
them okay in that case um the the last
thing I'll mention is is that um you
know as we saw before the the the flow
of the uh initial state is going to be
an estimate of the partition function so
we can actually uh pull that out here uh
by just
feeding an empty list to face DET tensor
and passing that to to our function
approximator and we'll see that our Pro
function is is not correct it should be
12 uh because we have uh four good and
four bad uh four happy and four sad
faces and we have twice the reward for
happy um so we' we've done something
wrong I mean what we did wrong was that
we didn't train for long enough but
actually we've done a bunch of things
wrong this is you know a very naive
implementation and uh one thing that we
we could do that would make it much
easier to learn this would be to prevent
the model from making bad decision in
the first place because we know that
adding two eyebrows on top of each other
is a bad idea or two mouths on top of
each other is a bad idea so what we
could do is we could mask those actions
during the sampling of the forward
pass and sampling of the forward
trajectory and uh this is a very very
common trick that's done uh when
training uh gonets on anything that's of
a reasonably challenging uh scale
because you're wasting a ton of time
sampling bad
configurations uh and learning not to
sample them um if you don't do this um
so oops I'm GNA go here
again what what the the next thing we
need to do is to figure out how to uh
prevent the the model from uh sampling
bed configurations and that's going to
be done using a a simple Boolean mask so
the goal here is to calculate from the
current state what uh the mask should
look like uh for the next um
iteration um and in order to do this
you're you'll need this feature Keys uh
list the indices of it basically so
that's why I have this printed here for
you so I'll give you a moment to to try
that
out
all right I I've thrown the um the
answer to this one up as well um so you
know because of the construction of this
uh this list it's you know we basically
just masking the first two elements if
there's already a mouth present the
second two elements if there's already a
left eyebrow present and the final two
elements if there's already a right out
present then the real question is now
that we've calculated this
mask what should we do with it and um so
here what I've done is I've given you
the same training Loop now with sort of
the the most of the elements filled in
for you but you have to use the mask in
order to uh prevent the model from
sampling bad configurations during U the
for um so I'll give you a moment to to
try
this
someone brought up that just in case
somebody else was confused by the same
thing um on the schedule the the links
are at the top of the the day two
schedule this is based on a notebook by
manual uh that's posted in the resources
um but the that notebook is quite
different and uh yeah it's not
structured the same way so um yeah make
sure that you're working with the collab
from from
here
so after you filled in the masking you
should be able to train
um train this and um Oru some plots
below um could you uh could I see a show
of hands of of who's been able to
produce that
plot a few okay I maybe I'll give some
more time
then
okay
all right in the interest of time I'll
um I'll move on so um this uh this L
training Loop here has has the masking
operation filled in um and if you were
able to train this model what you can
what you'll see as an output is a
comparison of what happens when you're
are masking invalid forward actions
versus and not doing so and this just a
demonstration of how this can really
help convergence when you're training
these models uh with a fixed compute
budget um I I I'm I'm having a bit of
trouble seeing from up here is everybody
able to get these models training
properly or is there are there
issues okay I'm going to assume that
means that everything is going well and
I can move on um so what we can see here
is is that uh we're doing better we're
sampling um now valid faces um all of
the time we're still not uh sampling the
correct proportion of of happy faces um
and our estimate of the partition
function is uh better but it's it's not
correct um so what we're going to do now
is to move to a a better you know loss
function as as pred uh presented by Quia
before trajectory balance so we're so
using the same compute budget here we're
now going to be implementing um uh a
loss that requires both forward and uh a
backward policy and an estimate of uh
log z uh
directly so we'll Implement our new
model here
um where essentially uh the first uh six
elements of the output are going to be
our forward policy the last six elements
of our output are going to be the
backward
policy and uh it will also have a single
parameter that is an estimate of log
z um so
oops I go back here so the the next uh
part of the exercise is to implement uh
the trajectory balance loss which is
given to you here um that will accept um
log of PF log of PB the reward and log c
um in in order to uh to to train the
networks
yes
uh quick note um uh log PF if you look
at the training Loop below is
accumulated it's not a it's not a vector
um so if you run to uh a weird bug due
to shape that might be
why okay uh I'm going to flip to the
answer here just in the interest of time
I'm guessing people are starting to get
hungry and uh we may not be able to
finish the whole exercise
um so what you can see here is is that
it's we're simply returning the sum of
log P log PF the log of the reward
that's passed to this function as well
as log PB and then we're going to square
this um the other thing that we need is
um backward masking for for the uh
backward policy and I'm this is uh is
this provided yes it is provided um so
this is a uh one for any action that
could be that could have led to the
current state otherwise it should be
zero um I won't ask you to to do that
here um but now I think for maybe the
final major exercise is uh we'll we'll
complete this uh training
Loop uh that that implements trajectory
balance
um so what are we doing here uh we're
We're
looping uh through uh um our episodes
we're going to collect our our state
which is a list once more our model is
going to produce p um PF ofs and PB ofs
and uh we're going to initialize our our
accumulated log PF and log PB we're
going to do our our similar uh fixed
length uh
trajectory um we're going to be masking
our forward
actions uh but here since we're working
on log space the masking is happening a
little bit
differently um
and the the key elements that you need
to implement
[Music]
are
um where did I put them actually it
looks like this is all given to you so
the idea here is is that uh once again
sampling uh the the
action uh for for the forward trajectory
and we're going to calculate the log
probability of that action and and
accumulate this if at we're at the end
of the trajectory we're going to
calculate the
reward and um then we have to do uh
something similar for uh the back R
trajectory um so we're going to use the
model to calculate uh
PB and uh we're going to mask this as
well with the masking function that we
we have uh drived
before and uh crucially we'll be
calculating the log probability of this
backward
action I guess there is no fill in the
blanks here I think I made a mistake but
in any case that's fine because we don't
have too much time before lunch um but
make sure that this trains and that
you're able to uh see this curve below
which will uh show you both the the loss
and our estimate of of the partition
function
throughout training then we should see
that it converges to the exactly correct
value and that we're sampling not
perfectly but pretty close to the ideal
proportion of happy and sad
faces um which is uh you know this is
supposed to be a demonstration of sort
of the advantage of using uh this loss
um even in a an exceedingly simple
example um we're able to see a different
in in uh
convergence so please uh please play
around with this and um feel free to ask
questions if if you're confused about
any of the outstanding elements I'll be
happy to walk around um and then after
you're finished um lunch is uh to your
left and uh thanks very much for your
attention
AB
just uh so everyone knows oh is it cut
off I'll I'll be uploading the uh the
answers to all of this later if you're
interested in the same
location
hello
everyone hello everyone if you have your
um belongings in that part of the room
please move it on the other room uh
because we are closing this section for
the afternoon just because there will be
a social event uh after the the talk and
the Practical of the afternoon so we
need to a bit of privacy to not uh
disturb uh your uh session this
afternoon so if you belonging out there
please move it to the other side thank
you and uh enjoy the the
lunch
Sound Cloud yeah could remember the
name I have more stuff on B but it's
like a lot
of I
know yeah I've got so
I have so much that it's not online
this's a little bit more
Cur how do I my own
thing you s me on slack or something
I'll send you something
back what's your name I'm Carl Carl yeah
car with a
K I used to work with a guy who call
himself car with a K yeah
if you're looking for me on slack
that's I think gu with little knob what
yeah yeah
that's
awesome looking forward to hearing yeah
of course yeah I'll send
something
all there
hey Mike aren't
online
okay Mike one online
okay mik to
unlock Mike one Mike
Podium and Mike
three
together
hey this is uh this is Carl from Mila a
support you hear me right yeah I can
hear
you
perfect I can hear you too uh yeah you
can just go ahead and hit
play is
it yeah that's that looks
good uh could you just say a few word I
want just make sure we can hear you in
the
room uh yeah hello uh can you hear hear
me perfect yes yes we hear you very well
okay so uh we'll start be we'll we'll
soon be starting again so you'll hear
one of the organizers come to Thea to
the stage and then they will introduce
you yeah sounds good amazing thank you
thanks
k
spe
this one's gonna okay okay
sure
check
check check M
check and my
Che
yeah
right welcome back everyone
we have a few more presentations this
afternoon before we all get to enjoy the
social
portion if lunch wasn't social
enough so for next
presentation for our next presentation
our speaker unfortunately has to join
remotely and we hope that we'll be able
to see him on the screen very soon and
the speaker is Mo Jane who is is a PhD
student at Miller supervised by Yoshua
and his research focuses on experimental
design and probalistic
inference Mar are you
there hi yeah I'm here good take it away
yeah thanks Kia uh yeah hi everyone uh I
unfortunately can't see you but uh
thanks for joining us for this Workshop
um and uh today I'll be talking about
conditioning and just generally
conditional
gonets uh so before I get started uh
about conditional gonets uh uh uh I will
go over do a recap of what we discussed
uh in the morning what was discussed by
the other presenters in the morning uh
just a short recap because I know
everyone has had lunch and had uh I hope
a lot of fun and interesting
conversations but just so that everyone
is on uh back on the same page again um
and uh also since I cannot see the
audience uh if you have any questions
uh in the middle of the talk please feel
free to go to one of the mics and ask me
uh uh the questions otherwise I I I
don't really have a lot of uh feedback
here
um um yeah so let's get started so uh uh
let's do a quick recap of G flets so uh
from yoshua's emanuel's and K St one
thing which should be hopefully clear by
now is that guts are amti Samplers uh
which are designed to right
compositional structure to allow us to
efficiently sample from high dimensional
distributions now when I'm talking about
high dimensional distributions I'm
generally talking about things like
graphs sequences um or even continuous
spaces as we'll see later in the to by
um and uh the key aspect here is the
fact that we learned the stochastic
policy which sequentially constructs the
object uh that we're interested in so if
we want to generate a graph uh we will
generate the graph through a sequence of
steps where each step uh consists of
adding uh one particular building block
to the graph um and uh we want this
policy to generate objects in a fashion
where the reward uh where the
probability of a particular object being
generated is proportional to some non-
negative reward function that we have so
this non- negative reward function rfx
uh if it is bounded it defines uh it it
can define a probability distribution um
and we want to sample from that
distribution um and that's what G fret
allow us to do efficiently and that's
what we learn the policy for uh so let
us uh go over some uh some terminologies
again so the sort of generative process
is represented as uh this directed asli
graph uh in the directed asli graph the
first thing we have is this special
initial State S zero uh we have the
terminal States denoted by square uh by
a square in this particular animation uh
we have uh the intermediate States
denoted uh as the circular uh
intermediate States uh the actions are
basically the edges within this are
represented by edges in this directed
aular graph um and uh the trajectories
are these arrows which are just walks uh
in this graph um um or paths in this
graph um and a path which starts from
the sour state or f0o and terminates in
a terminal state is a complete
trajectory uh a few more uh things uh
that were also discussed uh so I will be
operating in the trajectory balance uh
terminology uh so no flows for now um so
uh we have this forward policy which is
just uh a conditional distribution given
a state you have over the children of
the State uh the probability of going to
the children um uh and uh using the
forward policy if you start at s0 you
can sample a trajectory uh uh by
iteratively sampling by yeah iteratively
sampling from this forward policy until
you reach a terminal State you will get
a
trajectory uh similarly we also have a
backward policy which uh samples uh
which uh maintains a distribution over
the parents of each state um and if we
start from some terminal State we can
sample a backward trajectory all the way
to the source State um as zero um uh
then we can also Define these two terms
uh the first of which is the likelihood
of the trajectory under uh the forward
policy PF which is essentially just a
product of the uh probabilities of the
intermed of the intermediate transitions
which compose the trajectory and uh we
can also Define the likelihood of a
trajectory under uh PB uh starting at a
particular terminal State uh PB tow of x
to given X um as the product of these um
uh intermediate Transitions and under
the backward policy and finally we have
the partition function which is just the
sum of um sorry which is just a sum of
the reward rewards at the terminal
States or which is also the partition
function of the distribution that we're
trying to s from um now uh the learning
problem that we have in G flets is we
want to learn this forward sampling
policy which goes from The Source State
uh to the terminal State uh such that
the marginal likelihood of sampling uh a
terminal state is proportional to the
reward so the marginal likelihood of
sampling a terminal state is essentially
a sum of uh uh the likelihoods of all
the trajectories which lead to that
particular State and we want it to be
proportional to the reward now as
Emmanuel and Kia discussed if we naively
try to satisfy this objective it's like
a lot of an exponentially large number
of constraints that you have to satisfy
at each of the uh States in um uh in the
states space uh but we can have like
some more high level objectives higher
level objectives which sort of ensure
that this constraint is satisfied on
certain objects so in this the case of
trajectory balance it is uh the
constraint satisfied over trajectories
uh so uh in simple words the trajectory
balance constraint just tries to make
the product of your partition function
and your forward policy to be equal to
uh the backwards likelihood of the
trajectory under the backward policy
times the uh the reward function uh and
you ensure this is true for all
trajectories um and this sort of uh
gives us this nice learning objective
the trory balance learning objective uh
which can allow us to learn the
parameters to these policies uh forward
backward policy and the partition
function uh through this nice uh squared
error um and if this loss goes to zero
everywhere then we uh recover the the uh
the desired policy which samples uh
marginal which samples terminal States
uh with the probability proportional to
the
rewards um so uh let's quickly go over
like just the general procedure of uh
training gonets and uh the reason why I
bring this up again is because uh we
will see how this differs for
conditional gonets uh when I talk about
them a bit later um uh spoilers it's not
different so uh to train a g flet we
first start uh as you might have
experienced during the Hands-On session
uh uh just before lunch uh we start with
some reward function that we're
interested in um and of course which
defines the space that we also want to
sample from um and we can define an
action space and a state space uh to get
like the generative process uh for um
what we're trying to
S
sorry and uh this gives us our D um and
then we initialize our um uh lock we
initialize our partition functions we
initialize our forward and backward
policies with some parameters Theta um
and then until some convergence
Criterion uh which will be actually
discussed a bit more tomorrow uh but for
now you can assume let's say the fixed
number of steps that we train for fixed
compute budget uh we run the following
we will sample some trajectory from uh
some exploratory policy uh which Jared
discussed a lot of options for uh
earlier in the morning so for example
Epsilon R Epsilon online um uh policy um
and then you just compute the loss for
the trajectory uh so in this case uh
this would be the trajectory balance
loss um and then you update your
parameters Theta using uh gradient
descent so fairly straightforward and as
a result you will get this desired
policy which samples proportional to the
reward um now um uh I also want to
highlight some key features uh that we
get out of gonets again as sort of
foreshadowing things that we will also
focus on for the conditional case um uh
but the first thing is you get an
estimate of the partition function for
free um and this is sort of um this
might seem somewhat um uh uh like uh
straightforward in some ways uh but it
is also not so like yosha also
highlighted earlier in the morning that
typically when you have a sampler you
don't necessarily get these
marginalization properties along with
the uh the sampler so one example of
that is just a partition function um and
uh this partition function can be useful
in a lot of applications some of which I
will discuss a bit later um now there is
this as risk on free because technically
you
are training your policy and you are
spending a lot of comput so it's not
necessarily free uh but you it's free in
the sense that once you you have a
sampler you get this estimate of the
partition function along with it without
any additional compute for uh for that
um uh the next thing is amortized or
fast sampling uh again uh something
which uh yosha and Emanuel highlighted
early in the morning uh is uh if you
train
the once you have trained your policy
when you want to generate samples uh you
can just take a like sample trajectory
uh using PF uh your forward
and you will get the samples from your
target distribution uh this is very
powerful because typically in mcmc uh
you would have to run your uh chains if
you want to get more and more samples uh
so this is quite important in scientific
discovery applications um and final
thing which uh Jared highlighted uh is
off policy training so uh in uh the nice
thing about the Gite learning objectives
is the uh trajectories that you train
from don't have to come from the policy
itself they can come from any policy as
long as the policy has full support um
and um we can compute this uh loss using
any offline trajectory so this gives us
a lot of flexibility in terms of how we
design our exploratory policy uh which
samples the trajectories for training uh
which can uh allow us to do very fancy
exploration things so for example the
Thompson sampling approach that um Jared
mentioned earlier in the day um so uh
this is uh the the brief recap of uh the
of G forets uh uh from the morning
session um if there are any questions uh
up until this point hopefully not but if
there are please feel free to uh uh ask
them now uh before we start with
condition G
for okay I assume there are uh no
questions because I didn't hear anything
uh but please stop me if there is
anything U yeah so let's move on to
condition gonets so to start let us
consider this uh uh motivating example
based on this very cool smiley face
environment that we have seen uh
throughout the two days of the workshop
um now uh let's uh say we are sampling
smiley faces um uh or faces uh they can
be Smiles or they can be frowns um and
uh along with this uh faces let me
introduce another random variable y uh
which is you can think of as a
description of the faces so for now I've
kept it simple so this description is
very basic so it's evil smile uh EV will
frown innocent smile or innocent frown
uh so it describes the features of the
eyes and features of the the mouth uh in
in the smiley face and um say I also
Define this uh reward function um yeah
this reward function which
uh uh which basically um U computes how
uh how well the re the face and the
description match with each other so the
reward function um for uh the evil smile
with the smiley face which has an evil
smile is to and uh the reward for the
smiley face which has the the evil frown
uh and the description evil frown is two
and so on so where where the description
and the face match the reward is to
where there is some ambiguity so for
example in this in this particular case
uh the this in this particular smiley
face it is hard to say whether it is
evil or innocent or it's both at the
same time so we give it a reward of one
um and where it does not match let's say
the reward is
zero now um let's say I want to sample
smiley faces for each of these
Expressions uh why or sorry each of the
descriptions of the Expressions why uh
so what the most naive way I would go
about this is I would I have like four
choices for y so I will have one gonet
for each choice of Y so simply I train
the reward function I fix the uh I I fix
the uh expression to be evil smile and
just train a g flet for that particular
reward function then I fix the reward
function with an innocent smile and then
I uh train the gonet with that invol
function and so on now u a lot of you
might have already seen what is coming
uh but it is not very efficient uh in
this particular case where we have only
four you can still sort of do that it's
fine it's feasible uh but if you
consider y to be uh a bit more uh um uh
High dimensional uh so instead of just
being two uh uh two words from this
select vocabulary it can be just natural
language and in that case it is not
feasible to have one single gonet for
each of these values of yse another
important thing uh to notice here is uh
the reward function which I showed
earlier uh for uh in both of the in both
the cases with the evil smile and the
innocent smile
this particular phase has the reward of
one so there is some information between
both of these um uh between uh both of
these descriptions which is common which
results in some common features in the
ex in the space of uh the faces so here
it's here it is very easy to observe
which is this smile the word smile it
appears in both of them so what this
tells us is there is some shared
structure which we can try to leverage
in order to make make this more
efficient and not TR like the as many G
rets as the number of uh these this
additional variable y that we have and
this leads us to the idea of
conditioning so instead of uh trying to
learn these uh uh y separate policies
for each of the uh conditioning Vari
each of the values of Y uh we can
actually learn a single conditional
policy which conditions on the value of
y um and and essentially what this means
is we would share the parameters between
uh each of these uh policies trained
with an individual wi so U essentially
let's say if we trained uh from the
previous slide if we trained uh uh the
gonet on each of these reward functions
uh we would get sorry we would get um uh
these four uh different policies uh what
we instead could do with conditioning is
just have a single policy which
conditions on this input uh on this
description why and uh what this amounts
to is just sharing parameters between
all of these policies uh and uh there
are several reasons why you want to do
that the first reason is it allows us to
model the shared structure in these Wes
so the Shar structure could be things
like the word smile being common but
more generally it could be some more
abstract structure so if you have
natural language in natural language you
can have a lot of Rich structure if you
have um
if you have uh something like images
even if you're conditioning on images
there is lot of structure to generalize
from in images so uh it essentially what
it does is it allows us to generalize to
unseen why which is an important and
very powerful concept uh so even if we
see let's say only a very small fraction
of uh possible natural language
descriptions we might be able to
generalize to some unseen natural
language descriptions uh assuming that
we have like enough uh diversity in the
data or in the examples of why that we
have seen so just as an analog analogous
example if you think about uh stable
diffusion or di style models they are
trained on they aren't trained on like
all possible English text and the uh
corresponding images but you see a small
fraction and you're able to generalize
this conditional model to some unseen
natural language descriptions of like an
astronaut on a horse on the moon that
sort of thing um so how do we actually
operationalize this in the context of
gfl Nets that's where conditional gfets
comes in so conditional G FL Nets in
general they're essentially just instead
of having a single dag we Model A family
of dags but the special thing about this
family is that it can be indexed using
this variable y that we introduced
earlier so what I mean by this is uh for
example if
your y can take four different values
you can have uh you will have four
different dags but which dag you end up
in is essentially selected by the value
of y that you have and what this amounts
to in in in a sense is just having this
conditioning variable as an additional
input to all uh your learning objects so
your flows your policies um uh and even
your partition function so conditional
gflow Nets um in very simple terms are
just have this additional input why at
each state um to all your flows you have
your conditional for forward policies
conditional backward policies and your
conditional partition function and to
wrap them all up we also have our
conditional loss functions so uh you
just take everything which was discussed
in the morning and you just add this
additional conditioning variable and
that's basically it um so uh what this
ends up doing is instead of having
instead of of modeling this any single
dag your chronet will actually model the
generative process uh which defines the
family of dags uh for all the values of
Y and if you are clever about how you
select the Y that you train for I will
get to this a bit later you can even
generalize to unseen
wise uh and this can be useful in a lot
of different applications uh some of
which will be discussed tomorrow and
some of which I will allude to a bit in
in later uh in the slides um but uh
yeah so before I move on to like how we
actually train conditional G flow Nets
and what are like some examples of how
to parameterized condition G are there
any questions um uh based on things that
I've have uh discussed so
far
okay uh I assume there are no questions
uh but again please feel free to
interrupt me if something is not clear
uh so let's see how do we train
conditional gonet so here I'll try to
contrast it with the procedure that we
saw earlier in the presentation um and
the things which are different from the
previous uh example will be highlighted
and red so to train a conditional G
flet you again start with the reward
function uh but you also start with this
additional thing P of Y which is just
some distribution which from which you
sample this conditioning variable y uh
uh so this can just be like a uniform
distribution over some data set of w
that you have or it can be something
more fancy depending on your uh
application and some of the examples I
will discuss uh in a bit uh but assume
that you have some distribution P of Y
uh you you then Define your state space
and action space for generating x uh you
ini initialize uh your partition
functions forward policy backward policy
but in uh but this time all of them are
the conditional version so you have your
conditional partition function
conditional forward policy conditional
backward policy and so on um and then
until convergence uh you follow the
similar recipe so first you uh sample uh
this conditioning variable from the uh
distribution that you uh you are given
um or you assume uh then you sample a
trajectory uh using your exploratory
policy but the exploratory policy again
here is a conditional exploratory policy
um and then you compute your conditional
loss again which is just a essentially
just the trajectory balance loss but
with all the conditional uh uh
components um I also noticed there is a
small type over here this should be PB
um um but yeah and then you update your
parameters Theta with gradient descent
and at the end you will get your
conditional policy so like I said
earlier it doesn't differ that much by
uh that much from just training a
standard gfet which you all did in the
handson session as well uh the only
difference comes in here uh the part
where you have to sample uh you just
have this additional step of sampling
your Y and you just change all your
learning objects into conditional
learning objects uh but apart from that
the procedure Remains the Same now there
are a lot some other things which you
need to be accounted for when you are
doing this so the first obvious question
is how do we actually parameterize this
conditional policy so one thing which I
mentioned was you can assume that this
is an additional input along with your
SK uh but how do we actually
operationalize this so there are a lot
of ways of doing this and uh there is no
single best way of doing it uh but I
will discuss some choices uh which could
be possible uh depending on the
application so the first one is uh to
modulate the activations in your policy
based on the conditioning variable so
what this basically means is let's say
you have your conditioning variable y um
oops
uh sorry
uh uh okay sorry there was some uh issue
here so uh
assume you have this conditioning VAR
okay this seems to be happening again
and
again um sorry uh so uh you have a
conditioning variable Y and you have
some embedding for this conditioning
variable y that you obtain from uh some
uh some encoder uh what you can do is
for your policy uh for some intermediate
layers in your policy you can uh uh you
can uh change the
activations uh or do an aine transform
on the activations uh which is defined
using the embeddings of your uh uh
conditioning variable so this is
actually something which is quite common
in the diffusion model literature this
is how people Define the time dependency
in diffusion models uh but the idea here
is also similar it's just an aine
transform which is dependent on the
conditioning value of the conditioning
variable
um uh another option is simply appended
to the input uh like I mentioned earlier
so this is very natural in in the case
of natural language so for example if
the conditioning variable here is a
question so what is 3 + 4 and you are
trying to generate answer to this
question uh spoilers which is something
we are going to discuss tomorrow as well
um uh but for now let's assume that this
is uh a question what is 3+ 4 uh and you
want to generate the answer to this so
you can generate it uh like when you
have when if you want to condition on
this particular piece of text you can
just append it at the beginning uh um of
uh of your inputs all the inputs to your
uh uh policy uh and that will achieve
the desired effect um another option is
is to do uh to append it in
representation space so we assume you
have an encoder uh for your conditioning
variable and you have an encoder for
your States and uh you just um uh take
the latent representations which both
the encoders produce and you concatenate
them and that's another way to uh
achieve this uh effect of achieve this
conditioning um so these are three
choices of course there can be a lot of
other ways to do this but um uh there is
no single best way and you might want to
try out things which work best for your
problem uh there are also other things
in terms of how we actually instantiate
uh uh the conditional Chief onet so for
instance you might want to share
parameters between PF and PB and Z which
are responsible for doing the encoding
so for example the encoder can be shared
across all like pfpb andc or uh some
parameters can be shared between PF and
PB and so on so there is a lot of
flexibility in terms of how you
parameterize this um and this
flexibility again also comes at a cost
that you have a lot of things to try out
uh but generally uh uh weight sharing
does not necessarily hurt performance um
as long as there is like some reasonable
number of parameters which are set
independent for each of the sorry for
each of the
objects
um and the final thing is uh this P of Y
which I mentioned earlier uh what this
allows is it allows us to Define some
preferences if we if we might have any
on the y or the conditioning variables
um and even things like specifying
curcular so you can start from simple
examples of why and then slowly go on to
difficult examples of why and uh one
specific case of this uh is something uh
called temperature conditioning which
I'll get to in the next slide which is
also uh one of the questions on on on
zip um so uh but before that let's let's
let's look at some uh other in
interesting instantiations of this
conditional gonet framework so uh the
first one is this preference conditioned
multiobjective optimization so what
exactly is this uh set of words saying
uh so this is uh the multiobjective
optimization problem which essentially
means instead of having one reward
function uh say you have multiple
different reward functions uh so for
example in the case of drug Discovery
you can have how good is a particular
drug but your other objective might be
how toxic is it to humans and ideally
you would like to minimize the toxicity
to humans and while being very effective
uh against the drug uh sorry against the
target uh but the problem here is uh the
these both of these objectives might not
be independent of each other so uh
making a drug more and more potent to a
virus might um make it uh more and more
harmful to humans as well so there is
this tradeoff that you have to strike um
and uh essentially this is called the
par to front in multiobjective
optimization where uh you cannot improve
one objective uh anymore without hurting
the other and
sorry uh so in this case one strategy to
do um uh multi multiobjective
optimization is this thing called
preference conditioning where
essentially we assign some preference to
each of the objectives and depending on
the value of the preferences we uh uh we
focus on that objective so for example
in this point to the top left uh has
very low weight on objective one and
very high weight on objective two and
the point on the bottom right is very
high weight on objective one low weight
on objective two and so on so in this
case if we want to learn a policy which
can solve these problems what we would
do is we would condition on the
preferences assigned to the objective so
we want uh G which can condition on the
preference and generate uh candidates
which follow those preferences and the
reward is again also defined given uh uh
this uh preference Vector which is uh
just a weighted in this particular case
uh another example of where uh
conditional GS can be instantiated is
that of parsing uh so uh in parsing we
are given let's say a particular
sentence and we want to infer uh the par
tree uh if we want to infer a par tree
under some grammar that we know uh now
uh they can in general in in language
you can have multiple ways in which you
can pass a particular sentence uh but
here is one particular example so in
this case you would condition on the
sentence that you start with and
condition on this sentence you would
like to build this tree bottom up in
this particular example so we would
condition on the cad string t uh and
then uh these uh the tree which is being
built in in the in these panels uh is
the state space that we're operating in
so here uh we condition on the input
sentence and the reward again is uh in
this case we are trying to infer the
posterior overt trees uh so the reward
here is defined also in terms of X um so
the I I didn't go into a lot of details
on both of these applications but these
are part of papers which are on the
website so feel free to go there but the
the point here is to highlight uh how
conditioning can actually be instan
iated and in in a particular problem um
uh now the final more interesting case
is that of temperature conditioning so
um earlier in the day Jarett talked
about how important it is to and even
Emanuel talked about how important it is
to have uh some temperature on your
reward uh when you use it uh for your
gonet and uh temperature condition in
the IDE temperature conditioning is what
if you actually condition on this
temperature uh so what this does is is
if you condition on the temperature uh
and let's say you the conditional reward
here is uh just the reward at that
particular temperature what this allows
you to do is you can actually have some
sort of analing procedure so you can
start with um very uh High values of the
temperature uh which will give you more
exploratory behavior and um slowly uh
reduce the temperature and reducing the
temperature can make your reward more
and more peaky and at the end you can
get like very uh very greedy samples
from the modes of the distribution um
and uh because the uh model is uh
conditioned on the temperature you can
once your training is complete let's say
you have seen enough number of
temperatures you can actually get
samples from any temperature uh uh that
you uh that you want and this gives you
a lot of flexibility in terms of being
more greedy in terms of being more
exploratory and so on so this is also
another interesting instantiation of
conditioning which can be applicable in
basically any uh G flet
application and finally I wanted to
discuss uh intractable sums this is
again something which Yoshua alluded to
in his presentation earlier in the day
um but one sort of nice feature about
gonets is being implicitly Computing
these interactable sums these marginals
so in uh in conditional gonets we get
the pre for free an estimate of this
conditional partition function um and
this condition partition function
actually
encodes sum uh the sum which basically a
sum of this reward function which is
defined over two variables and we sum
out one of these variables um and we get
this interactable sum and this uh this
is an actually an very important uh uh
uh quantity in a lot of scientific
problems so one example which uh which I
I I'll discuss a couple of examples but
one of them is path integrals and
quantum mechanics so in the path
integral formulation of quantum
mechanics you have let's say you want to
uh study the probability amplitude of a
particle going from point A to point B
uh each of these trajectories can be
assigned some like all the trajectories
growing from A to B can be assigned some
weights uh which I denote here by R uh
if you consider like the sum over all of
these U uh trajectories um this uh it
corresponds to the probability amplitude
of a particle actually going from uh
point A to point B and this is a very
important thing which people study in
quantum mechanics uh which is uh uh
which is an example of these uh uh
intractable sums another example sort of
closer to home to machine learning is
latent variable models uh so if you have
a posterior distribution over some
latent variable
uh U the conditional partition function
actually represents the marginal
likelihood of the data in this
particular case it can it is in general
an intractable quantity uh but can be
useful uh as a di agnostic tool or for
various applications as well so the the
the idea here is that g like through
conditioning gonets can sort of uh be
even more flexible and sort of be
applied to a variety of different
problems and uh uh do more interesting
things um uh so that's basically it for
my presentation if there are any
questions I'm happy to
answer
would anyone with questions please come
up to the
microphones hi hi M can you hear me yeah
I can hear you all right all right um my
question is I understand it's not
exactly the same thing but um how would
you say that uh prepending the Y the
conditioning variable to the state space
to your environment as maybe the first
action that your gent can take how does
that relate to the conditioning scheme
that you described uh one one difference
I could see is that for example PB
wouldn't have access uh to it from the
beginning uh or maybe be sampled last it
would be fine like is it is it the same
thing do you see any difference
there um uh sorry so do you mean that uh
what is the difference when
we uh like if we are prepending it to
our safe space uh like how is it
different from assuming that basically
making it an action yeah like that can
choose on it on its own instead of
having an external py that you define
yourself yeah so the the the difference
here is like as you already alluded to
it's the fact that the the backward
policy for example does not have access
to the if it is an action that the backp
policy does not have access to this
initial action um and it is not
available at all states uh what we want
is to be uh it to be available at each
state as like an uh uh even when you are
sampling from the backward policy or
even if you're Computing the backward
policy um so if you assume is an action
then it is not necessary like you can
sort of make your mdp in a way that it
is uh condition like it achieves the
same effect uh uh so yeah it it is
possible to like just change your mdp so
that the assuming that it is an action
in your mdp so like if you structure
your mdp appropriately then it becomes a
conditioning variable uh but it's it's
easier to think of it as just like an
additional input present at all states
um it in terms of like actually like
instantiate instantiating
it all right thank
you hi Mo you hear
me yeah yeah thanks for the talks I was
wondering um is it always better to
condition or would there be cases where
like having separate ginet like a better
solution than condition
uh that's a it's a good question uh uh I
don't have a clear answer to this um I
mean if you have like like it's just for
example two things that you want to do
in and if the two things don't share any
structure at all uh then there's no
point in conditioning uh like if the
conditioning variables takes two values
and those two values have nothing in
common conditioning doesn't buy you
anything and in that case you can
probably just train two separate G flets
um uh but um it's uh like so it's hard
to say in general but for example like
if there is clearly no structure which
is shared between this this conditioning
different values of the conditioning
variable then you probably might want
not want to condition maybe Kola has
something to add to
that oh wait to put me on the spot I
have one thing to add to the excellent
answer which is that there may be cases
where you want to pre train your model
as a conditional one and then f- tune it
specifically for the condition values of
the conditioning variables that you're
interested
in the pre-training can help you adapt
very
fast okay
thanks so it seems like there are no
more questions yeah right thank you very
much M thank
you
next I'd like to introduce Lena nalin
who is a PhD student at udm and Milla
supervised by yosua her research
interests are at the intersection of AI
and Drug Discovery with a particular
interest in applications to uh curing
cancer and she will tell us about
training gonets for maximum
likelihood
um hi everyone so in this presentation
we're going to explore explore some
links between gonets and maximum
likelihood estimation so until now we've
always talked about gonets as this uh
framework where we have reward in the
end that we can train with but how about
if we don't have this reward and we only
have a data set that we can uh train
with
um yeah so before starting I want to uh
acknowledge Shu Kia and D who uh were
also working on this so sh was was
supervising me when I was working on
this direction and it's K and D who came
up with this idea and uh brought a paper
about it so you can check this very nice
paper which makes links between gonets
and other generative
Models All right so for the motivation
um so we've seen that Jon can sample
given a reward function so this is an
example of a negated uh reward function
for terminal States in R to the power of
two but how about if we don't have this
reward signal how about if we only have
some samples from this reward
distribution and you can see these
little Color Dots here uh and so we have
access only to this data set
here another way to look at it is um in
this uh little drawing so in the left
side it's the setting that we are used
to we have a jlet we have a reward
function that we can query for any data
point and this this can be in a setting
where the road is very cheap to compute
uh there is then this Middle Ground
where you have reward function but only
for a finite number of data points uh so
this can be the case for example if you
have molecules and
proteins um and the reward is their is a
function of their potential energy but
this potential energy can be expensive
to compute especially if you have large
proteins and then here on the right hand
side it's our setting that we're going
to talk about today so we only have data
and um it can be for example the data
set of text of images Etc
um okay so for the motivation of this g
g m it's very intuitive we start with
terminal States from our data set that
we sampled and we know that the these
samples are good according to some
underlying reward distribution we sample
a trajectory backwards and then we uh
want our G to increase PF for this
sample
trajectory um so in more mathematical
words words sorry uh we want our jet to
maximize the log likelihood of our
observed data but it's hard to optimize
this thing directly so uh what we do is
we optimize a surrogate loss called
elbow which we've heard about yesterday
morning uh and so the idea of this elbow
is exactly what is written here we start
with the terminal State X we sample a
trajectory backwards and uh what we want
to do then is to um increase the forward
PF for this trajectory to and so here it
is now we have a loss to train our gfl
net and there is no need for any reward
signal so we introduced the scale
trajectory balance loss which depends on
pfpb and your um terminal States
X um so this is the algorithm to train
our gonet mle we have a training data
set and um we sample uh terminal States
we sample a backward trajectory from
this terminal State and then we compute
the scale loss and we simply uh back
back prob for PF and PB through this
scale
loss um so this this algorithm works and
we can we can train like we can train
the whole jet M just with this algorithm
and train both PF and PB but there is
another way of doing it and it's we'll
see in the end that it's equivalent but
this way I find it more intuitive and um
the idea came from Kio so the GTH losses
all contain this reward signal and this
is problematic in our case so how do we
get rid of this reward signal well we
can use two trajectories instead of one
and uh look at and yeah these two
trajectories need to end up in the same
terminal State and when you look at
their TB loss uh what we can do is
combine these two TB losses in a way
such that the reward is going to cancel
and we are left with this new loss that
we call the consistency loss between two
trajectories and the terminal State and
it's basically just the difference
between the log of the different of the
the fraction of PF divided by PB for the
given
trajectory so um another way to look at
it is that uh from this elbow
calculation we can show that the log
likelihood of our training data is
maximized is maximized if and only if PB
PF and PB are proportional given a
terminal
State um and that means basically that
this um quotient PF divided by PB does
not depend on the trajectory that you
take it's it should always be equal to
the marginal of this terminal States
when our gonet has
converged um yeah so the idea is that
instead of using this scale trajectory
loss we're going to update PB by using
this new consistency
loss so you might be wondering okay but
what does it mean intuitively this
consistency
loss and this is a very um simplified
example so we have a a simple gonet with
two trajectories one that is black and
one that is gray and we have one ter
terminal state with the reward equals to
one and so PF and PB are going to be
like at the beginning they're
independent they're they're they're not
they they're not necessarily consistent
with one another and what can happen at
the beginning of training is that for
example the PF for the black trajectory
is uh going to have 75% of the weight
and of the Great trajectories is going
to have um 25% of the weight and you can
see that this is not consistent with uh
the drawing that is on the right where
uh PB for the black trajectory is only a
quarter and p uh PB for the gray one is
only three divided by four so we we have
that uh PF divided by PB is different in
the two cases and it intuitively doesn't
make sense because we want these two
things to be uh consistent with one
another and also another thing is that
we can use this consistency loss um also
we can see it as a reg regularization
loss that we can use with other losses
like TB loss or or yeah any loss related
to the
trajectory okay so now you might be
wondering um does this like how this how
does this consistency loss relate to
this scale trajectory loss for Pb do
does it mathematically makes sense is
there a relationship and it turns out
that yes um if we name five the
parameters of the backwards probability
it turns out that the gradients of the
consistency loss and the gradients of
the K loss are the same up to a constant
so this is this proves the correctness
of optimizing PB with using this
consistency
law uh so what we can do this time is
that we're gonna optimize the forward
policy using the first loss that was
introduced uh which is just take the
terminal stat and make sure that you
increase PF for these good trajectories
and then we can make sure that all of
the rores that lead to the same terminal
stat are going to be consistent by using
this consistency
laws um so we obtain this uh other
algorithm so we have our training data
set again and uh we sample a terminal
State we sample two different
trajectories toe and Tow Prime that both
end up in the same
x uh we compute the K laws uh update the
parameters of the forward probability
for this k loss and for the PB we're
going to use this consistency
loss and that's it that's the whole
algorithm okay at this point you might
be wondering again okay but why do we
need all of this we already have other
generative models we have diffusion
models we have vaes why why do we why
are we using
gonet but is it really that different
and this is uh what dqu shows in this
paper unifying generative models with
dlon and Beyond uh so it turns out that
there is um a very um close link between
all of these Frameworks so for example
for hierarchical variational auto
encoders which is this framework where
you have um like hierarchical latent
variables this H is this is exactly
similar to training the gonet and you
can uh Define the trajectories of your
gonet as being this Su this succession
of the latent variables the decoder is
going to be the gonet forward policy and
the encoder is the gonet backward policy
and you train your hvae using the KL
trajectory balanced loss for both the
encoder and the decoder so for both PF
and PV like the first algorithm that we
saw okay but how about for for um
diffusion models well diffusion models
are a special kind of gonet so I don't
know if the figure is visible but um in
diffusion models you have your initial
image and then you add some noise to it
to obtain um like a noisy sample in the
end and this is the forward diffusion
and this forward diffusion is exactly
the same as the backward shonet policy
where you have your terminal State and
then you just deconstruct
it um and the reverse diffusion is the
same as the forward gness policy where
you have some noisy thing and then you
want to sample a good sample so it's
like just opposite words but they're
referring to the same
thing um so diffusion models have some
specificities in that the intermediate
and the terminal states have to be in
the same space like for example in here
all of these states are
images um yeah the backward probability
is fixed so it's a gion and we know like
what is the amount of noise that we add
at each step and what we learn is the PF
and more specifically like we we
parameterize again PF as a gan and what
we learn is this uh mean
new and again you can find more details
about all of this in this
paper um yeah so that's it for the
theory and for the experiments we run
some very simple experiments on
different 2D toy data sets where the
data sets consist of these 2D
coordinates and um we train our gonet
with with the samples from this data
and in the end of training we are going
to sample some points and plot them so
this is what we see in the this top row
here uh and yeah sorry this gonet is
trained with the second algorithm so we
use scale trajectory balance loss for PF
and we use the consistency law for PB
and on the bottom you can see samples
that are from the true data distribution
and it like the g planet is doing a good
job in general except maybe here for the
moons where it's not that perfect but uh
in general it is able to fit the
distribution uh so that's it thank you
and I'm happy to answer any
[Music]
question thank you
Lena thank you Lena um so you focused a
lot on on the like the consistency loss
which is basically operating over the
the whole trajectories can we have
something similar at the level of like
some more local information like this
what what I have in mind is going from
trajectory balance to for example
detailed balance we have something like
some kind of consistency losses that can
do that as well uh so you mean can we
Define consistency loss but for like
locally is that yes um
I think it makes it makes sense to me
that it should be the same
thing
um I need to think about it a bit more
uh but I think it should also be valid
locally because you always
want like given two trajectories they
that end up in the same state it means
that they have the same flow in the last
um state so you still want PF divided by
PV to be the same but yeah it's like
there there has to be an intersection at
the beginning at in the end and and in
the end okay but yeah that's just an
intuition I I need to write the m to be
sure about it thank you that is a good
question so has there been experiments
uh using consistently loss in uh outside
of the maximum lik framework no there
hasn't but there are plans to use
it like uh we we haven't thought about
using it as a regularization objective
until like two days ago when I was
talking to some friends about it so
yeah so I have another question um you
mentioned that with the maximum
likelihood training of G Nets uh we end
up with special cases corresponding to
existing approaches like um VA I mean
hierarchical vaes and things like this
and diffusion models
is there any advantage
to like putting these methods uh Under
The gfl NET Framework does it buy us
something that
we might not have thought about before
we realized that these are special cases
of
gonet that's a good question and I don't
know
um like maybe that's that's just an
intuition but for example maybe you can
relax these conditions of diffusion
models where you constrain PF and PB to
beig ORS and maybe you can learn more
complicated U distribution that can be
more expressive and can help for the
training so in um I know that in in
chemical chemistry applications they use
diffusion models with
extra uh object jectives that they want
and they use some euristic where during
diffusion they go in the direction of
the gradient of the um property that
they want to
maximize um so I wonder if this is a
scenario where the G flet perspective
could be uh less of a
hack uh so do you mean in chemistry we
use the samples but we use another
signal that yes okay exactly so
typically they would have both uh a
training data of samples but they also
have some NE
net that computes properties that they
want to have so uh think of it like we
have examples of uh um you know good
compounds for a particular task and we
have a NE net that predicts toxicity so
we'd like to have compounds that look
like the good ones but also are not not
toxic so is it a bit like having samples
but also some kind of reward function
yes like both the two of them
yeah so you cannot train with a reward
function with for diffusion models but
for gonet you can maybe use both uh and
that's that can be a powerful Advantage
but yeah I but nobody has tried that as
far as you know I mean in the
gfet community uh sorry nobody has tried
that kind of thing like
combining a data set for which
you um I mean so so it's not what we
have tried is we have a data set and we
have a reward function and the data set
is just a guy to make sure we get the
right reward but this is a case where
you have a data set that gives you some
information and you got a also some
extra like like a separate objective you
got also a reward function that tells
you some things you'd like to achieve in
addition to the implicit information in
the data
set so it's an idea for a new
project oh
yeah
yeah by the way thank you for the
excellent talk so actually so one thing
we'll hear there might be more questions
Alena so um so one thing we'll hear
about in the talk by CM which is coming
up next is continuous gonets and
actually this view of diffusion models
as uh gonets train with maximum
likelihood allows us to train diffusion
models to match a reward function and we
have uh we have experiments in which we
do pretty much exactly what you just
asked about where we for instance we've
tried to train a gonet for maximum
likelihood like a diffusion model and
then for instance fine tune it or use as
an auxiliary objective a um reward
function and I don't know about
chemistry but it's useful for inverse
problems for instance where the prior is
given by a pre-trained diffusion model
and we have an extra likelihood which is
the evidence that we want to multiply
into it to get the posterior great
thanks sorry I can't hear
you like the data set is referring to
something but the reward is not like
it's not a reward function it's like two
different yeah two different
yeah two different objectives as long as
they don't contradict each other that's
possible yeah right thanks for letting
me insert this I think now kran has a
question it's it's just a comment on the
same thing uh it could also be but it's
it's a common question but like U is it
not like the strength of gonets here
would be also hard constraints like when
I think of the the crystal uh jlet work
with with Alex it's like when you have
those for example symmetry constraints
uh or you know what whatever other hard
constraint that you have it's the
masking in the state space is actually
something that's easier to do and
Implement and enforce with G instead of
having that in the losses of a
systematic Network that so I I think
that's also one strength uh for the same
for the same setup if you have hard
constraints that you know from your
domain I think gence give you more
control
there
um so is it also possible with the uh M
framework to train the gonet with a
fixed backward policy the same way that
you would do with the diffusion model
and bypassing completely the consistency
loss uh you can fix the backward policy
and find one one forward policy that's
going to work for this and just just
maximize for the okay the K loss yes yes
it's totally possible okay thank
you
H thank
you so now we'll take a take a break
until
3:30
e
I'll
this
there
yeah
um hey everyone just want to make a
quick
announcement uh maybe like a week ago we
sent you a link through EV bright um to
kind of submit your ideas and get
feedback I think there was something
like G clinic in the email title um so
you know we've had a few very
interesting responses but tomorrow we're
going to have about an hour sessions so
if you can uh have some ideas that you
want feedback on either prepare them for
tomorrow the mics will be open or go and
fill in that form already and uh we'll
try to think of some good answers in
events so thank
you all right um next I'd like to
introduce salamu who will talk about
continuous gonets in continuous State
spaces Salam is a PhD candidate I think
about two weeks away from being a
PhD
PhD PhD period
yes at ATA supervised by yosa and he
during his PhD has worked on uncertainty
estimation and
on theory for gonets and currently he's
interested in automatic curriculum
learning and in using gonets for
reasoning s can you say something yes do
you hear me fine and see my screen fine
good and you can hear us good I do hear
you I don't see anyone but I guess
that's
normal I think that's normal all right
thank
you great thank you for joining my
presentation about continuous gflow Nets
uh this presentation is mainly uh
following a paper that was published in
icml this year which was joint work with
trist Pablo uh
dingu Alex Sasha
Lena uh Kia and Yoshua I hope I didn't
forget anyone I should have written that
uh I guess like the first question to
ask is why do we need continuous gfl
Nets and you have probably understood
from the previous presentations today
that gfets have proven advantages either
theoretically or experimentally compared
to mcmc compared to reinforcement
learning and to variational inference so
compared to any of these
three domains like there are gonets have
some advantages for example of policy
learning helps gifl Nets more than
version inference uh we can sample
proportional to rewards rather than
maximizing reward as in reinforcement
learning Etc and also these proven
advantages have been confirmed in many
discrete domains discrete scenarios for
example in biological sequence design
where the goal is to construct molecules
or biological sequences by concatenating
small building blocks such as small
molecules or
maybe small proteins in
general it has been confirmed in ban
structure learning where the goal is to
learn a a graph or a duag that describes
the generative process of a given data
set and here the construction of such a
dug is done sequentially by the addition
of edges directed edges between
different nodes it has been confirmed in
the robust scheduling problem where the
goal is to assign a set of operations to
different compute nodes or threads which
is known to be an NP hard problem and
the G flets have been shown to be useful
for that and actually it's it's uh it's
probably still state-ofthe-art
today uh it has been used for discrete
image
modeling this is a paper that was
published a year or so ago where and the
image you see here is bin binarized Mist
where we construct these images of
numbers that are uh binary so just ones
and zeros uh given like a set of uh uh
of images and the way this is trained is
with maximum likelihood training that
has has been presented by in the last
talk and probably many I mean not
probably but like surely many other uh
discrete scenarios in which gonets have
been have been proven to be
advantageous so with these two points
the fact that there are many advantages
and the advantages have impr proven in
discrete domains uh there is the
question I mean the fact that there are
many interesting sampling problems that
do not exhibit this discret like
structure uh you know this is what
drives us to uh create a theory for
continuous gfet and these problems that
do not exhibit a discrete deck structure
I'll I'll cite a few of them the first
one being ban structure learning with
parameters so if we go back like to the
Bion structure learning in the discrete
case where the goal was just to learn
the the graph which is a discrete object
because we just need to create to to
create edges or like to learn where
where to put edges between the nodes
here we also want to learn the
parameters and the parameters are
uh in such a basian basian dag uh the
parent of a node influences its children
and this influence is captured by a
function that can be parameterized
either as a linear function or by a
neural network and in addition to to
learning the edges that tell us which
are the parents and which are the
children we also need to learn the
parameters of these
functions uh another interesting problem
is learning molecular confirmations so
in addition to learning the the molecule
structure uh we also sometimes need to
learn the angles between some of the the
edges or maybe like the bonds that's
maybe like the more correct term in
molecules uh give given that these
angles influence the energy of the
molecule some molecules with some angles
are more stable are more suited for for
a given
task and finally a last task that comes
to mind is image Generation Well colored
image generation where we we are not
limited to only ones and zeros where we
can choose what color we want for every
pixel and obviously you can think of
many other scenario
where the sampling problem does not
exhibit the discrete deck
structure so I believe like with these
three points uh it's obvious that uh to
ask the question of whether there is an
equivalent of Defence in the continuous
domains and whether these advantages
transfer to The Continuous
domains and before answering the
question I will give you a summary of uh
of uh of the paper of the of what we
found while working on this and the
answer is yes and there are few details
to be aware of when training a g flet in
a continuous domain and I'll start by
reminding you of uh the two main losses
that are used in the discrete settings
the detailed balance and the trajectory
balance uh and for the detailed balance
I'm not writing the the boundary
conditions where we incorporate the
reward but you know like
that's that's something that that should
be added to the detailed balance of
course and I just want you
to to see that here in the detailed
balance and the the trajectory balance
the policies we we care about are
parameterized by their prob Mass
functions so the the pmf here it's the
PO Mass functions the policy PFS Prime
given s is a probability Mass function
condition s and sometimes we need State
flows so as Kia mentioned when when we
when we don't use the flow matching
conditions we need extra objects such as
the state flow function and the backward
policy which is also a pmf uh and for
the tri balance but also for the balance
of course we we need the reward
function so for the continuous
counterpart we also have a detailed
balance and trajector balance
losses uh and the equations look very
much like the discrete ones except that
now for example for the detailed balance
we do not deal with pmfs probability
Mass functions but we deal with PDFs the
probability density functions so here
pfss Prime is a probility dity function
of S Prime condition s uh same thing
instead of a state flow function we have
a state flow density function and I'll
I'll talk a little bit about the details
later and again uh instead of the reward
function we talk about a reward density
function but besides these three
differences also of course for Pb the
equations look pretty much the
same uh so we can maybe like stop the
talk here and say that yeah of course
you can turn a g flow that just use PDF
uh instead of pmfs and use the same
losses with the in the log domain to
make it more
stable uh but I'll delve a little bit
into the details
now so the first question uh that's
which is important to answer is you know
in the discrete domain the structure is
well described by a dag we have parents
we have children we know that in order
to go for from one state to another we
have to go through this dag this dag
captures the structure we want uh but in
continuous domains it's a little bit
unclear how to talk about or how to
generalize the concept of children or
how to generalize the concept of parents
it might be a little bit weird to talk
about Continuum of children or Continuum
of
parents uh but still we need a way to
describe something that looks like a dog
structure in a more General
space and uh so we need some
mathematical tools to replace this dag
that we use in the discrete domain uh
and we need this mathematical tool to
satisfy a few thisit the first one being
we want to be able to describe a
Continuum of children or and parents as
I mentioned uh and we want discon to
with ar arbitrary Dimension meaning
meaning that you can have one state that
has a unidimensional set of children
where you know like the children lie in
a line or maybe a b dimensional set of
set of children where uh the children
line a square or or a dis or something
like
that and the second thing that we would
like is the ability to mix between both
continuous and discrete
components uh because there is no reason
to restrict ourselves in the to The
Continuous setting only and one example
or corollary of of this thing that we
want is
the yeah so we want the child set of a
state s it can be the union for example
of a continuous subset of the state
space uh and the exit State and this
exit state that we denote SF sometimes
uh basically if if we are able to
describe a child set that is this Union
of continuous and this Singleton called
SF this literally means that we can
terminate trajectories early so we
cannot we do not require the
trajectories to have the same length
and uh just because we want trajectory
to not have the same length we need to
be able to describe child sets that
include this Singleton SF that uh will
refer to Formula One to by the exit or
the terminate
State and I'll just show you few
sketches of examples of environments
that satisfy this this
desata here in the bottom left corner we
consider an environment uh which is a
square so our points lie within this
field Square it can be anything within
this Square
and we can consider uh the the starting
point to be the bottom left corner and
then we can move anywhere within this
quarter dis that is shaded here in Gray
so by quarter dis it means that the set
of children of s0 the start state is a
continuous component of the state space
and it is B dimensional because again we
can move anywhere in the dis and not
just the circle but after this first
step we can constrain the following
steps to be within a quarter Circle and
I believe that you see it a little bit
uh here like we have for example if you
are in this point here then the next
state can lie within this quarter Circle
here that is
centered around the the current state
and of course it has to lie within
within the
square and uh so so this sketch here
shows two trajectories of the different
lengths for example here after three
steps uh it was decided to the policy
decided to terminate so it went to the
exit State whereas here it required a
few more
steps uh another example that we would
like to be able to solve with with our
theory is the one where the number of
steps is fixed we start from an abstract
State S zero that does not represent any
physical property whatsoever but then we
will make for example 100 steps and at
each steps at each step we will sample
from a fixed distribution I mean not
fixed distribution of course like we
need to learn the parameters of the
distribution but like from a
distribution of a fixed family for
example we can set the family to be to
be Goan and if our space is R2 like the
the ukan space we can just have for
example gions with with fixed mean and
learned variance or gos with learned
mean and fixed variance or things like
that and after each step we will sample
from
Aion until we reach the 100 step then we
have a state at which we are obliged to
terminate and as a last example before
deling a little bit into the theory
which I promise won't be very
mathematical is the the image generation
problem uh where we start from an empty
canvas that's s0o then we have to choose
which
positions pixels to fill in and which
color to use for those pixels for
example here the set of uh of children
of s0 is a
Continuum
because sure there's a finite number of
positions just nine but there is an
infinite number or like a a continuum of
values that each pixel can take and
interestingly uh some states can have
multiple parents for example the state
here that has red and blue in this
positions have two parents here because
here the the forward policy has both a
continuous and discrete part this the
discrete part is the choice of the
location the pixel and the continuous
part is the choice of the color but the
backward policy only has a discrete
component uh here like if we want to
choose what parent S2 has we just need
to remove one pixel so and the number of
pixels is
finite so this is a one typical
application of continuous
Chets so I mentioned before that we need
uh a mathematical tool that allows us
to describe a Contin of children of
arbitrary dimension iions and that
allows us to mix between both continuous
and
discrete parts and the appropriate ma
mathematical tool we came up with is
transition kernels and very broadly
transition kernels can be seen as a
generalization of the concept of
measures I won't go much into the
details and I invite you to read the
paper if you want like the M
mathematical details but these
transistor kernels are basically
functions that take as input a state s
and a set a subset of the space and this
subset of the space we call it b b
belonging to this set Sigma here and
basically it tells you whether the set B
is accessible from s that's what you
need to remember from this so if Kappa
SB is positive it just means that part
of the set B is accessible from s it
means it contains some of the children
of s if it is zero it means that b is
not accessible from s and of course
there are a few
Kats with open closed sets again I won't
spend much time on it and going back to
the previous
examples uh where we had the quarter
disc and the quarter Circle we
can uh consider these two points here
for s0 for example Kappa s0b is zero if
if B is outside this quarter disk and uh
so that means that the support of Capa
s0 is the quarter disk and if you are
not at s0 if you are at another Point uh
then the support of Capa s is the
quarter dis for example if you are at
this point the support is the
corresponding quart sorry quarter Circle
not quarter
dis of course we have to add add uh to
to to add the
Singleton SF to mention that we can exit
at any
point uh for the other example where we
start from an abstract State S zero and
take a fixed number of steps our state
space uh is this abstract s0 Union uh so
we have to add a time stamp to our to
our states which are just normal vectors
so the support of Capa s0 is basically
the ukan space but we need the time
stamp to be one so we need states of the
form S1 and if you are at a state St
then the the support is the states of
the form s
t+1 uh so with this in mind like with
this transition kernel as the basis of
of our Theory uh the generalization of
the dag that we came up with we called
it uh we called it measurable pointed
graph I promise I will not read this
slide but this is just for reference and
maybe like if you want to ask questions
later but you know it requires the
specification of the state space and
these kernels that tell us uh what are
the children and what are the parents of
every state uh I will however mention
these two last points here which are two
important points uh that you need to be
wary of if you want to train a
continuous G FL
the first one is you need to make sure
that your trajectory lengths are bounded
meaning that you do not want some of
your trajectories to
have you know an infinite number of of
steps so that's something that you need
to enforce in in the design in the
design of the environment and of course
there is a mathematical formula for that
and you also need to ensure that all
states can be reached from s0o meaning
that there is no part of the the state
space that is unreachable
again of course there is a mathematical
formula for that uh I will summarize now
the key differences and similarities
between discret and continuous gonet so
in the discrete we talk about the
children and parents of estate s whereas
in the generalized gence we need to talk
about supports of measures Capa and Capa
B we don't need to spend a lot of time
on measures it's just like the
mathematical tool that that is required
for the for the theory but
but I just want to highlight that there
is an equivalence for the notion of
children and parents uh and instead of
the state flow function we need to talk
about a flow measure now and this
measure can have a density
you uh instead of the Ford policy we we
need to talk about a Ford kernel that
has of course a density that we call
that we write by small PF this is the
the backward policy we have a backward
kernel that again has a
density and instead of the reward
function we have a reward measure that
has a
density uh again these are just uh
mathematical details but at the end of
the day we have losses that look exactly
like I mean at least for re reward
matchine detailed balance and bance
these losses look exactly like the their
discrete counterparts and let's just FOC
Focus for a second on the detailed bance
one uh where you know instead of the the
state flow function f we have the state
flow density U so that's u s so Theta is
just the set of parameters and instead
of the probability Mass function PF we
have the probability density function
small PF and same thing here in the in
the denominator and of course we have
pretty much the same thing for the
trajectory balance loss that is applied
to trajectories of length n
and we don't need to spend time on flow
machine but there is uh some small
differences with the discrete flow
machine and that's because of the choice
that we made in the design of uh of the
structured space uh but all in
all the training strategy is exactly the
same as the one uh with the that you
have learned for the discrete gfets you
sample your trajectories either
according to the current forward policy
or kernel or you can add some noise to
it if you want to go off policy if you
want to explore the the state space more
efficiently and once you have that
trajectory uh you either decompose it
into transitions if you want to use the
detailed balance or consider the
trajectory as a whole if you want to use
trajectory balance you need to evaluate
these terms that are inside the loss and
in order to do that you you just need to
make a few forward passes neur neural
networks because basically this uh this
density you flow density you or the
forward kernel density PF for backward
density PB they're all parameterized by
neural networks that take as input a
certain State and once you do this
these forward passes you get what's
inside the square here and you know you
can just evaluate the loss gradient step
uh update the parameters repeat until
you're satisfied with the
results so that's about it for the
theory and I'll spend the next uh five
to eight minutes talking about a few uh
experimental results we have and then
we'll have some time for
questions uh so as a validation of this
Theory so this is not like a a really
interesting in use case of gonet but
should be seen as a validation of the
theory we consider a continuous version
of the hyper hyper grid toy task so this
hypergrid toy task has been used in many
JLo papers including like the original
one by Manuel uh so the state space is
this Square 01 squared and the reward
function is sparse that has four modes
and the modes are represented by these
four small squares by in
yellow and the transitions are follow
the the the example that I showed a few
slides ago that's actually I will show
again uh they follow this rule here we
start from a zero we need to move within
the quarter circle of a given radius
that we call row uh for the first step
and after the first step we can either
terminate or move within the quarter
Circle again of the fixed radius or now
I'll go back to the other slide
uh but basically once we have this uh
this strategy that describes our
measurable point of the graph basically
it tells us what are the children what
are the parents of every
state uh we so this design basically it
makes the environment satisfy the
constraints that we had before so all
the the equations especially the last
two ones that I said that trajectory L
needs to be bounded and all states
reachable by uh by S zero so this is a
fied and you can convince yourself with
it I suppose pretty easily uh so uh in
the second image so this one here we see
samples from a GI net Trend with
trajectory balance and actually it's not
really sample so we tret we get samples
from that and then we fit kernel density
estimator and we get this nice uh
control plot uh and the the choice of
the policy we we we made is uh that's
why we have circles or discs instead of
squares it's it was like hard to I mean
it's you can probably prove that it's
impossible to reach Square uh densities
like this like with step function uh
with the choice of densities we
made so there is an important caveat of
continuous gifl Nets that I would like
to highlight here so in discrete gifl
Nets and this is actually for the next
three figures that I will explain so for
the discrete gonets the policies whether
it's forward or backward they're
parameterized with logits so the neural
networks that take as input EST State s
they output logits that represent the a
categorical distribution because we have
a finite set of children and we just
need Logic for that
but with continuous gfets we we have an
extra degree of freedom because we need
to choose uh the family of distributions
we want for example we can choose our
policy to be Goan and for that we need
our neural network to Output the mean
and the variances or maybe just the mean
uh as a function of the current state
uh here for this example we we chose a
mixture of beta
distributions and why it's beta
distributions so beta distributions are
continuous distributions
over compact domains so it's
bounded as opposed to gions which are
unbounded so that's why whichs betas and
we chose it to be like mixture of betas
in order to to describe a richer family
of distributions so if you use this
mixture of beta distributions we need to
Output the mixture parameters that you
know parameters that tell you uh I guess
you know what mixture of distribution is
I don't need to explain that and we need
to Output the concentration parameters
of the
betas so this poses some something to be
you know it leads to something to be
extra careful about uh basically we need
to make sure that the family of
distributions we are dealing with can
satisfy the detailed balance or the
trajectory balance conditions because if
we choose like a poor family uh maybe we
can never reach a zero loss because as
in like the detailed balance or TR
balance can never be
satisfied so this is what the next three
figures show so the first one so this
one here what does it show uh we
consider a uniform backward policy so uh
by by that I mean that every state has a
Continuum of parents that belong to a
quarter Circle that is in the bottom
left uh of that state of course the
radius row so we start with this uh
backward policy and we start with
samples from the reward distribution
like we we directly sample from the true
reward like because it's a toy task we
have access to the true reward and with
these samples we take backward steps
using the backward policy until we reach
S1 S1 meaning the state that comes right
after s0o so that's why we get a
landscape or a support that is within
this quarter dis so this is row that is
the the radius and basically we bring
back the samples to S1 and we we fit a
kernal density estimator and we get dist
distribution here so this is the
distribution uh that this is what the
forward polic at is zero should lead to
and you know like there is a huge mass
here on the left Edge on the bottom Edge
there is some Mass here in the middle
and it's pretty hard to match that uh on
one step using a mixture of
betas uh whereas if we consider a
learned backward policy then uh the the
if we do the same process of starting
with sample Su the reward and bringing
them back to S1 uh then we get this nice
plot here where the mass is more regular
and it is easier to match that with a
forward policy that is a mixture of
betas and this is represented by the
fifth figure
here and what this
means basically is
that whether it's detailed balance or
trajectory balance these conditions are
satisfied better if the backward policy
is learned meaning by satisfied better
it means that the loss reaches something
that is closer to zero and this is again
shown by the Learning curves here in the
bottom uh maybe you can just focus on
trajectory balance the in blue for
radius equals to
025 where we see that if we fix PB to be
uniform then we Plateau to something
that's around three to 3 * 10 Theus 3
whereas if we learn PB as well then we
are allowing PF to
match this learn PB more easily so the
the the detailed balance or director
balance condition is satisfied more
easily and we are able to uh to reach a
lower value for the
loss and of course this is also apparent
in detailed balance and also apparent if
we change the the
radius uh I'll stop talking about this
example now I I guess I spent more time
than expected but i' be happy to ask
questions to answer questions about it
later on and I'll quickly talk about
this uh task of learning molecular
confirmations for so we are given a
certain molecule where the atoms are
fixed but we have two degrees of freedom
which are these two
angles C and Fe or yeah and basically
these two
angles they influence the energy of the
molecule so the molecule is more stable
given some configuration of these two
angles so one particularity of this T
and of this task and this is why I'm I'm
talking about it is that the state space
has an interesting topology uh because
these angles basically let's called they
live within zero 2 pi and you know 2 pi
is the same thing as zero in if we talk
about angles uh so if we talk about just
one angle we are talking about a circle
because 2 pi is the same thing as zero
and if you talk about uh two angles we
talk about a circle that is horizontal
and a circle that is vertical to that
and we are given a taus and taus you
know something that looks like a donut
so our state space is a tus it's not the
normal ukan space and you can think of
it this way basically this space that is
represented by a square you can you
should wrap it wrap like w r a in your
head uh where the right Edge is the same
thing as the left Edge and the top Edge
is the same thing as the bottom
Edge uh so this is a projection of a
Taurus in in the Square so this left
figure here we have the energy landscape
from which the reward density is
derived of this is the true energy
landscape that tells you for
given value of c and V what is the
corresponding energy and here in the
right figure this is the energy
landscape that is obtained by fitting
kernel density
estimator on samples from a train gonet
and we can see that we can match the the
true energy landscape PR accurately uh
but again like the the point of this
slide is just to mention that we are
able to to solve tasks that have an
interesting topology that is not just
ukian and uh finally as a last
experiment I'd like to mention uh this
uh this one about posteriors of graphs
and parameters so it's ban structureal
with parameters that I mentioned in in
the first slide I'll show it again
actually before going to the details
it's the the task here where the goal is
to start from an empty graph that
represents the nodes and uh then the
goal is to add edges sequentially and
once we are satisfied with the the the
structure then we have to learn the
parameters that are associated to each
one of those
edges and uh long story short is that we
we compare G flets to
uh the before
comparing what this task is is you are
given a data set of let's say three
variables uh so it's just a set of
points in three dimensions and the goal
is to construct the graph between three
variables that tell
you yeah which are the parents which are
the basically the graph that generated
this data and we did this with three
four or five
variables and uh back then and I guess
till now uh yeah sorry back then the
state-of-the-art algorithms were BCD
Nets and dips the they took this data
set and they output a posterior over
graphs and the numbers that you see here
are basically the Jensen shin and
diversions uh between the Learned
posterior and the true posterior and the
long story short like the lower it is
the better and what we found is that
with the G flets uh we we get
significant improvements so we
can like surely say that g are bit or
currently state of J algorithms I don't
know if something has come since then
this is like February
2023 uh
but either stateof thee art or almost
stateoftheart
today so this concludes my talk I just
want to shamelessly advertise this torch
gfn library that now supports continuous
Environ Ms and Joseph will probably talk
a little bit about that in the next
presentation and uh these are the ref
references that I used either the papers
or the figures that that I copied and
thank you for your attention and I'd be
happy to hear your questions
now anyone with questions is welcome to
up to the
microphones yeah uh thank you for the
nice talk now I have a question about
like which policies we should use in
practice so in my understanding that in
diffusion models like people for example
for images people use gum policies and
for molecular confirmation I think
people use graph neural networks or
something but I'm curious like in G case
like let's say I want a sample from just
exp the world function like which policy
we should use in plce depending on
domains so s you said exp sample from
exp I'm not sure question if the goal is
just to uh sample from exponential like
reward function like let's say the goal
is like standard gold in
gonet and the domain is continuous like
image or like molecular
conation which policies like uh do you
recommend to use in
this I don't think there is like a
generic answer to that it really depends
on the task at hand but if your domain
is unbounded then I would say that the
natural choice is to use a gion for
which you need to learn the mean and or
and variance uh but if your domain is
bounded then you need to consider other
distributions such as the one I
mentioned before like beta or mixture of
betas
uh but I suppose that you know like I
don't have an example on the top of my
head right now but there might be many
other settings where uh the distribution
you
are you should consider is more tailored
to the task at hand and one last point
is uh I'll go back to this slide here
where I mentioned that the choice of the
family of distributions is really
important because if you make the wrong
choice then maybe your detailed balance
or tror balance conditions can never be
satisfied
uh so yeah you need to be careful about
the choice of of
distributions uh thank you uh for the
molecular confirmation which policies
did you
use uh so this one uh it's followed the
the let me go back to this
slide it followed this example here
where there was a fixed number of steps
so it's it's called like stochastic
control with jlet where we start with
this abstract States and then we do 100
steps and uh actually I
forgot which distribution we used maybe
like col remember I think it's a gion if
I'm not mistaken because it's a
distribution for each Dimension you have
distribution over the circle I think
what was used as a mixture on of Fus
distributions or maybe circular gaus
Alex actually maybe can answer this
better yeah I remember yeah it's a it
was 10 steps in the paper and a mixture
of
uh five components five for
distributions yeah the details are in
the thank you very
much thank you for your
question there any other
questions no okay uh thank you very much
salm we'll resume in we'll resume in 15
minutes with the second uh Hands-On code
tutorial of the day but before that
let's thank the speaker one more time
thank
you
for
spe
yeah it's a good idea let people cheat
if they want to yeah no that makes sense
I uh I can do that
thing especially because I have 15
minutes
for
e
push the the solutions uh
on okay
okay we're ready to resume in just just
a couple of
minutes we're good to go Oh in fact
we're good to go but maybe the audience
is not good to go
yet right so let me reintroduce Joseph
who will lead the second practical
session on the of the day in which you
will train a simple continuous chlo net
enjoy thank
you
let's get
online so um to facilitate uh this
session I've put the answers uh up for
both the first uh problem set but also
the moment we're about to do so you can
have a look at the answers as you're as
you're working through it um thank you
uh um although I'll continue to do the
cooking show format um so the the goal
of this session is to to do the simplest
possible version of what CM just
described to us um uh it's it's almost
cartoonishly simple I don't think you'll
ever actually use a continuous g-l net
under these uh to do this sort of thing
but hopefully it allows you to
understand a few of the Core Concepts
and at the end of this tutorial are
links to a much more realistic and
interesting um continuous gonet
implementation uh in uh in the the gonet
library which is being developed here at
MAA that I would encourage you to look
at if you're interested in using these
things um so the first step U after
you've got your your notebook set up is
to um you know as before do your Imports
and uh run this hidden cell uh which
will then show you the hyperparameters
that we'll be using for the beginning of
our
session okay so as we talked about uh
already the big difference here is that
we're going to be using our function
approximator to predict the parameters
of some distribution we're going to be
sampling from instead of predicting
discrete
actions so this actually gives you a lot
of power um as a designer when you're
trying to figure out um exactly what how
you want want to Traverse your problem
space um and uh for whatever uh uh set
of solutions you're trying to
sample um there's a lot of flexibility
here so you know if you're predicting
the parameters to say gotian
distribution you can then sample values
from that gaan and you can use it to
modulate your current state in various
ways or you can just reset your current
state to be those values these are all
design decisions that you have to make
um in our case we're going to be
considering um any value that we sample
to be a Delta of the current state so
we'll simply be adding whatever we
sample from our Gan to the current state
so s of T plus1 will equal s of t plus
this
Delta um and uh a key thing here is that
the distribution that we're sampling
from can be a mixture of of many
distributions that CM talked about we
won't be talk we won't be tackling that
here due to just time constraints and uh
the level of complexity that it adds but
I want to stress how important it is
that this part part be taken with care
because it it's really a big um uh it's
a it's a great way to introduce bugs
into what you're building and and it
introduces a lot of complexity and the
example the example that I point to at
the end of this tutorial uh covers that
uh very
well okay so what is our environment uh
what we are going to be doing is we're
going to be sampling from a mixture of
gaion we're going to be learning to
sample from a mixture of gions so reward
distribution will be defined by multiple
gaussians each defined by a mu and
sigma um and the other thing that we're
going to need is an initial value s0o so
I um just below here I'll show you
there's a rendering of of the
environment we're going to be um
traversing so the the game is we're
going to be starting from s0o and then
passing that state the state being uh
the current exp position to a function
approximative which is not going to
predict the values of a um of a gausian
that we're going to sample from and
we're going to try and move around such
that at the terminal state will end up
in that location proportional to uh the
reward value that you see here and so
this function that um this little class
that I've defined here allows sorry my
computer is a bit slow um uh allows us
to Define multiple environments of
varying complexity given these uh values
of we pass in so we we'll do this a few
different times with different
environments um so you should be able to
just simply execute everything up to
this point and and uh view the
rendering and we can start talking about
uh policies actions and
states and so um as as we've said
multiple times we need a distribution
from which to sample our steps and we're
going to parameterize this uh simply as
as gaan so we're going to be predicting
the mean and uh the standard deviation
we're also going to put some in uh in
force that the standard deviation has to
be between 0.1 and one for now to help
with convergence and so that those are
some of the hyperparameters that were uh
you know given to you at the beginning
of the
notebook but um later on you can play
with these things and see how that
changes the behavior of the model so um
the first uh the first um function that
needs to be defined is something that's
going to take our our neural network and
our current state and is going to
predict the parameters of this gion and
uh and return it as our policy
distribution which is being shown here
so our
model um which uh will return a batch um
a batch Dimension and then two values
one for the mean one for the sigma and
then we'll just simply extract those
values although here we are enforcing
those constraints that I mentioned
before about the minimum and maximum
maximum value of that of of the um the
sigma then we're going to pass that into
a normal distribution and return
this so again again that uh I hope this
is all clear
um but our state actually includes
something else so the first element of
our state is the exposition we have
something else which is a step counter
and this is kind of important U although
I'm not sure how how clear that is
already um the idea here is is that you
know in FL in general we don't want
Cycles we don't want Cycles in our state
space but you can imagine in this
formulation it's very easy to produce
one you could for example sample an
action that's just plus one and then
another action that's minus one and
you've ended up back in the same
location that you started in um one way
to avoid this is to Simply increment a
counter for every step you take such
that you never end up in the same place
twice with respect to the state
space um here and also in order to make
our life easier I think uh before some
was talking about you know EG sampling
the exit probability in order to allow
for earli termination and these kinds of
things we're not going to deal with this
complexity either we're simply going to
terminate when uh tals 5 we take a
certain number of steps and and exit um
but there's definitely more
sophisticated ways to handle this
termination again the example that I
point to at the end um gives a good ex
uh good um demonstration of
this okay so here's our first like
actual uh exercise so what we're going
to be doing is we're going to be uh
taking a step in this space so we're
going to have an action which is um
sampled from our distribution our
AR and we're going to take our our um
State X and produce the next step of
that um very simply by incrementing the
the action and uh sorry adding the
action and increment the step
counter the other thing that we're going
to do here is we're going to initialize
the state which is to say that we're
going to uh produce of something that
starts at x0 and at T equals z um so
I'll leave you a moment to to fill these
cells in um or you can just copy them
from the answers if you
prefer
something I perhaps didn't make U
sufficiently clear is that the initial
value is stored within the line
environment at the beginning
so
so I have the answer up here um I I hope
that makes it clear the the structure of
what x um represents so this this
function will accept the
model uh sorry um uh the state and and
the action in order to increment
and uh this this function will
initialize our state which will allow us
to move on to more interesting things so
um this next bit is going to be I think
probably the the main chunk of of what
you'll have to do so we'll we'll leave
some time for it um but what we're doing
is a simple training loop we're going to
use trajectory balance um recall the
loss from before um so in order in order
to use this loss we're going to need to
instantiate a forward policy backward
policy and and then
oh I think I type here but um forward
policy backward policy and then our
estimate of log
set
and uh I believe I've implemented this
oh I'm looking at the solutions but I'm
pretty sure I implemented this for you
um so this is simply to say that we're
going to take in um our Exposition and
our count and we're going to
Output um the estimate for mu and sigma
both a forward and backward model log Z
is uh going to be a scalar that we learn
and uh one interesting trick here is is
that we're going to learn the um forward
and backward models with a slower
learning rate than log Z this is a
common optimization trick when using um
um trajectory
balance um so that's what this function
is going to be is going to do it's going
to run every single time you train a new
model which will initialize everything
for
you okay so uh now I'm going to show you
the the training Loop which has some
things you need to fill in um it's
greatly simplified why because we're
using fix length
trajectories um so we don't have the
probabilistic um exit
actions and what we're going to do is
we're going to use our forward model to
calculate a forward policy sample an
action from that policy and then
calculate the log probability of that
action which we're going to increment
onto log PF
um and we're going to store all of our
states in a trajectory then what we're
going to use we're going to do is use
that trajectory to calculate the
backward policy uh so that we know we
know which actions uh took us all the
way through and uh we're going to
evaluate the log probability of each
observed action under this
policy um the trajectory dimensions are
batch dim trajectory step and state
those are the the three um dimensions
and we're going to calculate the
probability of the backward trajectory
and accumulate this into log PP for to
calculate the loss um the log reward uh
is going to come from our environment
definition that uh we've given to you
above and uh I think that's that's all
you need to know so uh down here this
model again this will only take a few
minutes to train um and spoiler alert
does at least one bug in this that's
intentional so if it trains and it looks
like it's not quite right that's fine um
but uh go ahead and look through this uh
you need to um uh handle the sampling of
the the forward um the forward actions
and also the backward and the lost
computation I don't be afraid to ask
questions
how many people have successfully
trained something even if it doesn't
look
perfect did I give some more time for
this who would like more
time okay no problem
um for those who who don't know uh
distribution objects have a log prob uh
method that you can uh leverage which is
useful
um quite
I'm going to give uh just few more
minutes and then I'll I'll show the
answer to this piece which is probably
one of the largest parts of the demo and
then we can move
on
h
okay
all right so in the interest of time I'm
going to walk you through the
answer
um what we're what we're doing here is
we're going to
sample um from the policy distribution
we calculate using our forward model in
X to produce an action the we're going
to calculate the log probability of that
action under that that policy
distribution and accumulate that on log
PF here what's happening is we're going
to take a step using that action and
then we're going to add this information
to our trajectory and we're going to you
know assign new X to X and continue the
loop until we finish our
trajectory the next thing that we're
going to do is the backward backward
trajectory so what we're doing here is
we're going to get our policy
distribution with our backward model and
we're going to pass in some already
computed element from our trajectory our
action is the difference between this um
this point and the point that came
before in the forward
policy and our uh log probability of
that action is accumulated on the
backward uh log
PB finally we just uh fill in the the
loss here which is the trajectory
balance loss we've already seen
before and uh that's it now if you were
to train
this should take you about a minute and
a
half
oh um you can run this function here
which does inference so this just
samples a bunch of trajectories
um uh and uh gives us U we get the
terminal actions out of these TR the
terminal States out of these
trajectories and then we can plot them
using this handy render function which
will give you something that looks like
this which is bad uh we haven't sampled
the reward
distribution and the question is why so
um uh hopefully if you haven't haven't
been able to fill in the code you can
just copy stuff over from the solutions
notebook I'm going to move ahead because
I need to explain uh the bug that was
present in the previous training
move so what happened was during our
forward sampling we started at S zero
which is is predefined and then we're
sampling these U uh we're predicting the
parameters of gions and taking these
steps from those gions all the way to
the end of our
trajectory in the backward path uh in
the backward uh
trajectory we did the exact same thing
but the problem is is that at S1 we
sampled an action to get to s0 s0 is a
is a def point it's not something that
we could sample and hope to get to uh
with any level of
consistency and for this reason the
correct thing to do would be to treat
that jump from S1 to s0 as a known
entity with a probability of one and we
didn't do that and it's the the fix
turns out to be very easy although it's
hard to find which is in the backward
Loop the uh the way that we index uh the
range of this backward uh this backward
Loop it should end one earlier the
reason why is because of the way that
zero indexing works is in Python and the
fact that we're calculating the
transition between T and T minus
one and the fact that a probability one
event has a log probability of zero so
we don't need to bother accumulating
anything and so in this training Loop
which has everything filled in for you
except for one fix um uh you can
um uh produce a bit a much better um uh
sampler so I'll give you a quick moment
to run that and train it and then you
can look at the results from
this this is a very common
bug if if what I said doesn't make sense
please feel free to to ask questions
um the the beauty of these kinds of
interactive
tutorials
so if you change that number you get
this which is pretty good it's not
perfect but if we train for longer it
would be very close to perfect um and uh
we we've now learned how to to sample
from this mixture of two gums so I'm
going to make the problem
Harder by moving the gaans further away
we
start in a very low probability region
we need to learn how to sample from
these two gs that further away so I've
given you you can reuse the previous
function just train it yourself and see
what happens and this what what what
happens uh very regularly is the model
will learn how to sample from only one
of them and we not bother learning that
there's another mode out there sample
from and we heard earlier today about
how to handle this sort of thing we need
off policy
exploration and uh that the the first
thing that we need to do uh basically is
to Define our off policy uh method so
that we can sample from this uh and in
order to produce the exploration
required to find all of the modes and
since we're sampling from GS an easy
solution would be to just increase the
variance
of the thing that we're sampling from in
order to make sure that we're searching
why more on the left and the right of
wherever we currently are in order to to
ensure that we find those those um those
other regions uh on the number
line so uh I'm going to assume assume
that you're given a number of some
kind off policy noise and the goal of
this cell is just to produce a second
exploration distribution that
incorporates this information in order
to uh in order for you to sample uh off
policy I'll give you a moment to to do
this then the next major thing which is
integrating that into the training Loop
that includes off policy
exploration
so to give away the answer uh all we're
doing is we're taking the policy
um Sigma and we're going to add the
noise to it in order to produce the
exploration distribution we're going to
return that then the real question
becomes how to integrate this into our
training
Loop so in in the below training Loop uh
let's let's fill in all the necessary
pieces we have to
um Define the value that we're going to
increase the variance by this is what
we're going to pass to that other
function uh oops
um we could also put this on a schedule
that would be ideal so something that
you know starts from some initial value
and then de case towards zero as we
train uh you you can do that if you'd
like um then we're going to sample
actions from the exploration
distribution and then we're going to
calculate log PF using the log
probabilities of the samples from the
policy
distribution and so you can fill in
these pieces here in the in the training
Loop and then verify that you're able to
recover both modes in the
environment
has anyone been able to uh get it
working sample from Bolt
modes
yeah
does anybody want more
time yeah little
bit
okay
you oh but you oh
oops maybe that's
me
problem
um any case in the in the interest of
time I'll I'll draw your attention to uh
the slides or The Notebook on the screen
um which explains what to do so
uh if you wanted to do a schedule which
I think is a good idea and uh might be
necessary I'm not sure if anybody
successfully trained a model with out a
schedule um what you a simple solution
would be to start from some number and
then linearly reduce towards zero over
iterations so you can do that with just
a simple Lin space and then as you
iterate uh you uh simply index the
exploration schedule and you feed this
into your function that you previously
defined which is going to give you a
policy an exploration
distribution those two things uh here
and here uh you use the exploration
distribution to sample an action and
then you calculate the log probability
of that action under your policy
distribution the rest of the loop
Remains the Same I don't believe there's
anything else to do and if you were to H
this is trending on my machine if you
were to do that you should receive a
plot that looks something like this you
have successfully recovered both of the
modes
and okay so for the final example
because we only have a few more minutes
until we're all we'll
socialize um I'm just defining a sort of
harder uh environment now I have four
modes um some of these modes have higher
reward values than other ones and we're
going to Simply train once more on this
but I'm going to give the model Fighting
Chance so I'm going to give it twice as
long to train so go ahead and give this
a shot and see uh what the results look
like and if you're um if you're having
trouble uh getting things to work of
course you can always use the solution
notebooks to copy over um anything that
you need to
find
okay
so I mean hopefully it's all it's all
running for everyone um it shouldn't
work it did work you did Magic um but
what what we'll see here is that the the
model tends to prefer sampling from
these uh higher reward regions and
hasn't yet learned um how to uh sample
from this mixture of modes in the middle
here and this can be done if you train
for longer um it could also be done if
you were to better hyperparameters these
kinds of things um this is the reason I
do I'm showing you this is just to sort
of
highlight we have I thought we had three
minutes um uh just to highlight uh how
um even you know seemingly simple
examples can be can be hard to train and
how um uh
um carefully you'll need to tune these
um your models if you want to use them
in um to sample from these kinds of
distributions really the the reason I'm
showing this is because if you're going
to use this in any sort of application
that has you know a lot of dimensions
and these kinds of things I think things
can get quite tricky quickly and um I
would uh encourage you to sort of like
respect the challenge of applying this
method um in those kinds of domains um
to give you uh I think you have to do
this at home uh but to give you some um
intuition for how the differ uh
hyperparameters affect the the
convergence of this thing um I've given
you at the bottom of this notebook full
implementation as a single cell and you
can play with all the different
hyperparameters and see how that affects
uh training but the final thing I'd like
to to highlight uh before uh we we end
the session is um a much more sort of
realistically challenging example that I
um I wasn't sure that I could do justice
to within an hour but I think it's like
a really good way to uh learn about the
complexities and intricacies of using
continuous gfets so this is the
continuous Cube environment which is in
in a sense an n-dimensional
generalization of what we've done today
um from uh the gonet library which is
written by um multiple people that were
involved in the this uh this Workshop
um and uh you know there's some
instructions here on how to get things
set up and training um but the link here
just to highlight I make this go away
there we
go the link here to The Continuous Cube
environment um has excellent
documentation but it's also uh it's
quite long there's a lot of logic that's
handled in order to make this uh sort of
thing work um that we were able to avoid
because I oversimplified everything for
you um so if you're if you're really
interested in understanding how G uh
continuous G flow Nets work um I would
strongly recommend you go through this
this uh
is sort of extended tutorial if you will
or example in detail um it it it handles
the early termination oops handles early
termination um the action space is
governed by Beta distributions with
scale parameters so that you know this
is actually an interesting uh this adds
some interesting challenges when you're
calculating the log
probabilities um the forward and
backward actions are governed by
different distributions that's another
complexity that we avoided here um which
is something something that is very
actually very common when you're
applying these things um and yes I
already mentioned the L probability
things so I'm I'm really only SC
scratching the surface of uh continuous
gonets but I hope that this uh helps
ease you in some of these more uh
realistic examples that you'll find um
online thanks for your
attention
all right now I need to announce things
um there is going to be a social just
over here and there are drink tickets
with the uh wonderful organizers matu
and uh emanel who's I'm not sure I think
she's she's over here at the door um so
please uh grab some drink tickets and uh
enjoy the rest of the evening
yeah social event is until
uh 8:00 p.m. so there's food there's
drink and there's you to have F so
please
enjoy